zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live in ihrem live stream zur
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen die
inzidenz zahlen der kur witt 19 pandemie
sind in einem bereich der ja doch
hoffnung macht aber für einen guten
sommer und vor allem für einen guten
herbst und winter brauchen wir ja vor
allem viele menschen geimpft sind
aber es fehlt immer noch an impfstoff
soeben oder gestern kamen sogar die
meldung dass zum beispiel auch bayern
tag wieder die lieferungen
zurückschrauben muss das ganze also nach
wie vor eine ziemlich angespannte
situation und in dieser situation
kündigte der
bundesgesundheitsministeriums sparen
jetzt an dass menschen ab 12 bis ende
august auch ein impfangebot bekommen
sollen wenn die europäische
arzneimittelagentur am freitag ihr go
gibt dass der biontech impfstoff auch
für diese gruppe der impfwilligen oder
auch nicht freigegeben wird
das sorgt bei manchen für irritationen
unter anderem auch weil der ständigen
impfkommission denn dort zeigen einige
mitglieder öffentlich keine bereitschaft
diesen impfstoff zu empfehlen der
bundesgesundheitsminister will dass
sowohl trotzdem machen dass begleitet
heute den impf gipfel in berlin wo sich
bund und länder mal wieder
zusammensetzen um zu beraten wie es
weitergehen soll
wir warten auf die ergebnisse hier bei
der pressekonferenz und bis wir dort
wissen was beschlossen wurde sprechen
wir unter anderem mit dem spd
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach und
professor evers von der ständigen
impfkommission die beiden werden gleich
miteinander und mit uns und euch
diskutieren fragen und kommentare wie
immer gerne in die kommentarspalten wo
auch immer ist sie gerade findet oder
per mail an ze erfreute - live at zdf.de
außerdem sprechen wir natürlich mit
unserem korrespondenten in berlin das
ist heute thomas reich hat der das ganze
für uns begleitet hallo thomas hallo
also wieder mal ein treffen zwischen
bund und ländern was sind denn heute so
die großen themen die da besprochen
werden müssen also im grunde geht es vor
allem darum wie der knappe im stoff am
besten verteilt werden kann da gibt es
eine ganze reihe von konflikten das hat
man vor diesem treffen schon gemerkt
weit weniger harmonisch sein wird als
das was wir in den letzten tagen oder
bei der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erlebt
haben
es geht um die bundesländer hamburg und
brandenburg so nicht einverstanden damit
wie viel impfstoff sie in den letzten
wochen bekommen haben sie finden die
verteidigung ist unfair diese impfstoff
für teile mit ein großes thema sein dann
du hast es schon erwähnt die frage wann
gibt es impfungen für kinder und
jugendliche ab zwölf jahren das ist ein
großes thema bei dem spann vorgeprescht
ist zum ärger natürlich auch mancher
bundesländer wie gesagt haben wie kommt
er dazu warum redet da nicht mit uns
vorher und vor allem woher will er diese
6,4 millionen impfdosen der nehmen die
er da zur seite legen will wir haben
doch jetzt schon nicht genug
insofern ist auch wie entspannt selbst
sich ein thema jetzt bei dieser bei
diesem impfgipfel er wird ein bisschen
was zu hören bekommen das hat man aus
dem fragenkatalog der ahl ende der spd
länder gesehen hier sieht man es zb das
sind ihre fragen und da geht es unter
anderem um den punkt dem umgang mit
unrealistischen ankündigungen vom
bundesminister sparen hohe
erwartungshaltung also dass vor allem
die spd sind das vor allem die
spd-geführten bundesländer ist glaube
ich nicht also der unmut ist das was wir
hören da ging auch wirklich bei den cdu
ländern quer durch die bank das ist eher
eine ländersache die sich dann vom bund
übergangen fühlt und wir werden mal
sehen wie das so weitergeht was wir
gerade hören aus dieser runde ist dass
man sich trotz dieses konflikts offenbar
dann doch eine gewisse kompromisse
gefunden hat es könnte also durchaus
auch schneller gehen nicht bis spät in
die nacht davon ist auszugehen wenn wir
auf die wand ja und dann ist da schon
etwas neues zu entdecken
wir sehen da nämlich einen bildschirm
stehen an der stelle an der
üblicherweise markus söder sitzt also
der bayerische ministerpräsident ist wie
die meisten anderen offenbar zu hause in
münchen geblieben
aber wer ein söder ist er ist auch wenn
er in münchen ist in berlin absolut
präsent und offenbar villa auch bei
dieser pressekonferenz dann mitreden und
sein seine punkt position wieder geben
dass wir das erste mal wenn man gespannt
wie das dann aussieht
thomas fischbeck tun gucken wir mal was
denn so eigentlich die bundesländer
teilweise sagen das hat christian der
hübscher für uns zusammengefasst
seit drei stunden sitzen sie berlins
regierender bürgermeister müller kommt
dafür ins kanzleramt die meisten anderen
teilnehmer sind virtuell zugeschaltet
ein gipfel der zwischenbilanz so nennt
es jens spahn der am morgen einen
mobilen test bus in berlin besucht und
mal wieder versucht hoffnung zu machen
es geht jetzt noch um wochen nicht um
monate bis wir allen ein empfang gebot
gemacht haben werden können wenn es die
zulassung hergibt von 12 bis weit über
100 jahre
doch um die impfungen ab 12 gibt es
streit die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde wird die
kinderimpfungen morgen wohl zu lassen
die ständige impfkommission in
deutschland aber braucht für ihre
empfehlung noch zeit sollen wirklich
alle kinder geimpft werden oder zum
beispiel nur für erkrankte und wo kommen
all die zusätzlichen dosen her
die spd erhöht den druck abspann der
bundesgesundheitsminister hatte in
aussicht gestellte zusätzliche
lieferungen an die länder um
insbesondere auch schüler und
schülerinnen impfen zu können ob diese
zusage einhalten wird das eine der
interessantesten fragen die sich uns in
den nächsten stunden stellen werden ein
papier aus dem hause sparen zeigt
tatsächlich weist das
gesundheitsministerium nicht mit wie
viel impfstoff genau im juni und juli zu
rechnen ist
den mangel verwalten müssen sie in
impfzentren und hausarztpraxen wie hier
in stuttgart
die hölle los ich war zwar noch hinter
hölle aber hier schon eine sehr große
nachfrage nach impfterminen imf
angeboten
das telefon steht nicht mehr still und
auch darum geht es im kanzleramt den
start des digitalen impf nachweises ein
feldversuch dazu beginnt heute in
brandenburg die europaweite einführung
zum ersten juli wird deutschland wohl
terminlich nicht schaffen also ein
weiteres mögliches streitthema thomas
reichert in berlin wie stehen denn die
bundesländer wenn man mal bei diesen
fragen der impfung ab 12 bleiben zu den
plänen also herr weil hat ja schon sich
positioniert sagt er vermied das gut
gibt es auch ministerpräsident innen die
sagen nee lass mal lieber sein erst mal
alle anderen impfen
also bleiben wir vielleicht erst mal für
einen moment bei bei weil
ministerpräsident von niedersachsen der
da eine interessante position hat er ist
der meinung dass sollte auf jeden fall
gemacht werden
und er hat auch gesagt dass wenn die
immer dann morgen aller voraussicht nach
die freigabe erteilt dass man da auch
keine weitere meinung oder einer
stellungnahme braucht also im grunde ist
das ein misstrauensvotum wenn man so
will gegenüber der stiko auf deren
eigene einschätzung eigene expertise
weiter nicht warten will
der berliner regierende bürgermeister
michael müller hat ebenfalls erklärt
dass das geschehen soll und vor allem
hat er gesagt das muss dann schnell
geschehen denn in berlin beginnt in drei
wochen schon die ferien
bis dahin müssten im grunde schon die
ersten impfungen die erste impfdosis
verabreicht werden damit dann
rechtzeitig zum beginn des neuen
schuljahrs in berlin oder in brandenburg
dann auch die vollständigen impfschutz
gegeben ist es gibt da unter den
ministerpräsidenten den insgesamt keinen
großen konflikt ist eher die frage woher
sollen die impfdosen kommen was was hat
der bund sich dabei gedacht und
insgesamt natürlich dann auch wieder die
frage wie geht man denn mit
was hat ihr entspannt sich dabei gedacht
dass er diese wichtige frage nicht mit
uns vorher abgestimmt hat gestern gab es
meldungen dass biontech nicht so viel
liefern kann wie geplant heißt das jetzt
dass die impfkampagne zwangsläufig ins
stocken gerät oder kann man das
irgendwie ausgleichen durch lieferungen
der anderen hersteller also ausgleichen
wird man das so einfach nicht können bei
unter klar gemacht dass das sozusagen
eine liefer delle ist doch das ist einer
der punkte um die es heute oder jetzt
gerade im kanzleramt geht die spd
geführten länder an dass in ihren
fragenkatalog mit aufgenommen der
sonntag hat betont dass die liefermenge
insgesamt für dieses zweite quartal
eingehalten werden wird also
wahrscheinlich erleben wir in den
nächsten zwei wochen da einen mangel an
biontech impfstoff wahrscheinlich wird
es auch abgesagt die impftermine in den
praxen und in impfzentren geben aber
insgesamt das hat der konzern drückt er
die firma jedenfalls erklärt
wird es da nicht insgesamt einen mangel
geben aber es zeigt dass diese
impfkampagne die jetzt an fahrt gewonnen
hat trotzdem immer noch nicht sozusagen
das volle tempo erreicht hat und dass es
immer wieder stolpersteinen
verzögerungen gibt gerade deshalb ist
eben die frage so groß wie geht man mit
der impfung mit kindern und jugendlichen
um wie hoch sind die prioritäten
es kommt ja noch ein weiteres hinzu zum
siebten juni auch das ein thema jetzt im
kanzleramt soll die priorisierung
aufgehoben werden das heißt potenziell
halle dann zugang alle erwachsenen
zugang zu zur impfung aber noch mal es
ist eben nicht genug impfstoff da dass
jeder jetzt sofort gesagt noch vor dem
urlaub da etwas bekommen könnte wäre das
bei dir blinkt und du vielleicht eine
wichtige nachricht bekommen hat hieß
gerade aussieht guck mal nach und nach
ins land ist schon recht ich spreche ich
mal kurz mit unseren userinnen und usern
hier im chat gerne mal auf meinen
rechner schalten weil ich sehe hier
obwohl wir noch nicht so viele menschen
sind das ist ziemlich wild umher geht
bei euch und ich möchte euch doch
einfach bitten auch wenn das thema viele
emotionalisiert möglichst sachlich zu
bleiben
es gibt jetzt hier beschwerden warum
werden kritiker als schmuggler
diffamiert von shiva das ist darüber
passiert hier von palm beach das ist
nicht so sachlich kann man auch anders
ausdrücken
es gibt natürlich menschen die
tatsächlich sehr merkwürdige ideen haben
was die impfstoffe angeht und generell
das corona virus aber natürlich ist
kritik völlig in ordnung solange sie
sachlich ist und argumentativ auch
nachvollziehbar und wir werden hier auch
niemanden blocken oder sperren oder
kommentare löschen denn sich an die
netiquette halten der die haben wir
gerade auch noch mal hier rein gepostet
das haben die kollegin einem back end
gemacht hier gibt es einen kurzlink bei
konnte drauf gucken also bitte sachlich
bleiben so was wie sehe ich hier gerade
eine von gerd lappen behauptungen dass
sich jemand zum verbrecher macht das ist
echt schon grenzwertig weil es immer
noch eine meinung aber ich würde sagen
man kann vielleicht auch einfach ein
bisschen sachlicher bleiben so thomas
gab's was wichtig ist aus dem kanzleramt
hast du gerade eine nachricht bekommen
wie es aussieht
also die hoffnung ist nach wie vor dass
es schneller geht und dass sie offenbar
eine formulierung eine kompromiss-
formulierung gefunden haben
zur impfung von kindern und jugendlichen
wie die aussieht da müssen wir noch ein
bisschen warten auf die pressekonferenz
aber angesichts dessen wie viel da ein
konflikt in der luft lag vor diesen
treffen scheint es nun doch überraschend
schnell zu gehen mal gucken ob sie dann
wirklich schnell kommen
gut dann warten wir gespannt ob gleich
die pressekonferenz losgeht oder nicht
du machst du beobachtest für uns und
meldest dich sobald wir wort kriegen
dass es losgeht vielen dank erstmal und
wir stürzen dass es in die diskussion
und zwar haben wir gewinnen können den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
und professor hungers vizepräsidentin
der deutschen gesellschaft für
allgemeinmedizin und familienmedizin und
mitglied der ständigen impfkommission
ich grüße sie weiter
wir haben die große diskussion um die
frage ob menschen ab 12 geimpft werden
sollen wir hatten hier auch gestern
schon bei uns in der sendung im stream
zu gast professor fred zepp auch von der
ständigen impfkommission und der hat uns
gesagt die datenlage ist ihn zu dünn um
diesen impfstoff guten gewissens für
menschen ab 12 freigeben zu können frau
professor roma sind sie da mit ihrem
kollegen der gleichen meinung
wir haben dann weniger daten von kindern
und jugendlichen bisher und an derartig
kurzen vorlauf dafür gar keine
sicherheit staaten haben und das finde
ich ein bisschen wenig um daraufhin
entweder privat ihren 1131 menschen
waren glaube ich in dieser studie also
junge menschen einer studie
herr lauterbach reicht ihnen das um
sagen zu können wir können diesen
impfstoff für menschen ab 12 freigegeben
ich glaube dass das tatsächlich die
größenordnung ist die man benötigt um
eine empfehlung zu geben diese
empfehlung muss dann natürlich
entsprechend qualifiziert werden also
man muss darauf hinweisen dass das
unsicherheiten darin sind aber die größe
der studie die jetzt gemacht worden ist
die richtet sich danach wie groß muss
eine studie seien um ein klares ergebnis
zu bringen
und somit war eine größere studie
überhaupt nicht so rechtfertigen weil
das ergebnis war so eindeutig der
impfschutz war so stark dass nicht mehr
kinder in die also und jugendliche in
die also im studio hätten aufgenommen
werden können gut der impfstoff im
jetzigen zeitpunkt bei kindern und der
impfstoff wirkt da haben wir jetzt diese
aussicht aber wir können ja doch anhand
dieses beim sample sagte mir professor z
gestern keine nebenwirkungen finden oder
naja häufige nebenwirkungen würde man
schon sehen und selbst unter
nebenwirkungen sieht man in einer
solchen also studie phase 3 studie weil
sie die wirkung quasi also ab dessen nie
das ist ja auch behalten den erwachsenen
an dem stoff also bei den impfstoffen in
der anwendung für erwachsene nicht
anders gewesen weil in einer solchen aus
der phase 3 studien machen sie immer das
folgende sie machen die studie so groß
wie sie gerade sein muss um ein
statistisch signifikantes ergebnis für
einen wissenschaftlich aussagekräftigen
wirkungsnachweis zu erbringen und somit
werden seht und nebenwirkungen immer nur
gewonnen
und die kann man immer nur auswerten im
feldeinsatz das ist bei kindern und bei
erwachsenen so und also wenn man war sie
sagen würde dass man da sich an der
studie machen muss die hotels in der
nebenwirkungen bei kindern also schon
sicher erfassen kann dann müssen dass
studien sagen die viel größer sind als
studien die zum nachweis der wirksamkeit
gemacht werden müssen
frau professor thomas das hieße ja doch
eigentlich das dann so wie der herr
lauterbach darstellt eigentlich ihre
sorge unberechtigt ist doppelt sie
unberechtigt ärger auch gesagt dafür wir
nebenwirkungen die nicht extrem häufig
sind auf der bisherigen studien
überhaupt noch nicht erkennen können
dass sein herz und ich ja auch und
dagegen muss man abwägen das risiko der
kinder und jugendliche durch eine
erkrankung tragen dass gering aber
können sie das überhaupt jemals machen
also berlin wenn nicht an lauterbach
jetzt red i versteh eine phase-3-studie
ist immer nur so groß wie es statistisch
nötig ist das heißt sie werden in so
einer phase 3 studien niemals solche
nebenwirkungen finden können
ja man könnte schon das sicherheitstool
hier machen ich sage die
zulassungsstudie für den impfstoff für
erwachsene da hatten wir etwa 20.000
personen also dass es doch noch eine
ganze ecke größer
auch da kann man seltene nebenwirkungen
nicht ohne weiteres finden
aber was man im moment zum beispiel
machen könnte ist abwarten denn in den
usa werden bereits kinder geimpft dass
es dort so entschieden worden und man
könnte eine weile abwarten ob dort
nebenwirkungen meldungen auftauchen
während ist hier in keiner besonders
keine besondere eile gibt das wollte ich
gerade sagen denn kinder und jugendliche
erkranken wohl äußerst selten schwer an
cook 19 tiere nicht häufig aber das
automatische oder geringgradige
erkrankungen
ich schaue mal ganz kurz in die
pressekonferenz
herr lauterbach kurzen verrechenbar für
mode gerade gesagt das könnte sein dass
die pressekonferenz schon losgeht wir
gucken mal ganz kurz die das bild
aussieht aber tatsächlich bewegt sich
doch noch nichts dann herr lauterbach
geht das wort an sie also ist eile
geboten
oder können wir warten wie sich der
impfstoff in dieser jüngeren
altersgruppe in den usa und in kanada
verhält also ich werde zunächst sagen
hat noch etwas logo der logik also der
auswertung sagen und dann auf den punkt
zurück kommen dass alle geboten mit der
logik dass also ein impfstoff also erst
zugelassen werden da wo der empfohlen
werden darf genauer gesagt ist ja nicht
die zulassung seine empfehlung wenn ich
auch die seltenen also nebenwirkungen
kenne würde ich einen so impfstoff nicht
empfehlen können
aber ich habe am anfang immer auch bei
der erwachsenen also studie
vielleicht 10 15 manchmal 20.000 also
geimpfte und es reicht natürlich nicht
um seltene nebenwirkung zu sehen
somit also wenn es dann wenn alle länder
so denken würden dann wird kein land
jemals den impfstoff also einsetzen
können
bei wachsen oder bei kindern weil ich
für die seltenen also nebenwirkungen
einfach keine daten
aber was wir typischerweise machen ist
werden
also sind wollen sicher sein dass es
häufiger und schwere nebenwirkungen
nicht gibt wir achten auch auf alles was
aus einmal aus anderen studien darauf
hin weiß also phase-2-studien also
sicherheitsstudien tierstudien alles was
wir wissen und wenn wir dann wissen es
gibt keine häufigen nebenwirkungen und
der impfstoff kann als sicher betrachtet
werden
dann fangen wir dann an ihnen auch in
der fläche zu benutzen und schauen auf
seltene nebenwirkungen wenn die sich
dann zeigen brechen wir sofort ab so
würde ich auch bei den kindern vorgehen
heißt das und wir haben hier also aus
heißt das dass sie das gefühl haben dass
die ständige impfkommission hier höhere
sicherheitsstandards an liegt als das
normalerweise der fall ist ich will also
darauf hinweisen dass sind
sicherheitsstandards die wenn man sie so
konsequent so annähen anwenden würde
die würden dazu führen dass man also
fast nie irgendeine neben stoff zu
lassen könnte
das wäre nicht möglich weil ich habe
einfach aus der phase 3 nie genug daten
um eine wirklich selbst in der
nebenwirkung zu sehen daher muss ich
immer den sprung ins kalte wasser machen
von phase 3 ruhig gezeigt habe das wirkt
in die routine situation wo dann
eingesetzt wird und dann muss aber ganz
genau geschaut werden
also ob es nebenwirkungen gibt ja oder
nein aber der sprung ins kalte wasser
die nutzung in der fläche die würden nie
stattfinden wenn ich den standard zu
hoch oder ich müsste die phase 3 studien
so groß machen was ich auch seltene
nebenwirkungen sehe das wird aber bei
kindern hier bedeuten dass wir
beispielsweise eine studie machen
müssten
in der um die 100.000 kinder geben
würden
das ist gesetzlich nicht vertretbar was
wir wollen warum wagen sie den sprung
ins kalte wasser dann nicht warum wollen
sie die usa und die kanal und kanada
quasi so als feldversuch benutzen
warum ist nicht vertretbar wenn man dort
von 100000 kinder einfach nur helfen
will
aber das machen sie doch müssen sie doch
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe
sowieso bei allen impfstoffen immer
machen eben weil diese simple
gerade bei kindern und jugendlichen nie
so groß ist wie er gesagt hat oder hat
er da unrecht hat er nicht unrecht aber
dann eine nutzen risiko abwägung gemacht
werden und das hat dann müsste man ja
ins kalte wasser springen wenn die
gefährdung der zielgruppe in diesem fall
der kinder und jugendlichen durch die
krankheit so groß ist das gerechtfertigt
erscheint aber gibt es denn irgendwas
was darauf hinweist dass dies dann
irgendwas was darauf hinweist dass das
risiko so großes dass sie bei dieser
risiko nutzen abwägung sagen okay der
nutzen ist nicht groß gemacht das risiko
überwiegt das kann man im moment noch
nicht so fit zu versterben oder sehr
schwer zu erkranken für kinder und für
erwachsene völlig anders hallo herr
sommers ich muss nur unterbrechen weil
ich in berlin bewegt sich was die
pressekonferenz geht in diesen
augenblick los beratung der
bundeskanzler den regierungschefs der
bundesländer werden sie jetzt informiert
so also frau bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel ist da der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin
herr müller ist da und wie es aussieht
das herz oder per video konferenz dazu
geschaltet und jetzt hör mal was
beschlossen wurde bodensees nicht etwa
des chiemsees den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten meine damen und
herren wir haben heute einen ins
gespräch gemacht zwischen bund und
ländern das war glaube ich auch zum
richtigen zeitpunkt und haben im grunde
drei dinge miteinander besprochen das
erste war die frage der impfkampagne für
die kinder in dem zusammenhang dass wir
erwarten dass die zulassung der
europäischen medizin agentur für den
impfstoff biontech alsbald erfolgen
könnte für kinder im alltag von 12 bis
16 jahren bei uns ist ja bereits ab 16
jahren zugelassen
wir haben aus der europäischen
kommission auch gehört dass auch mutter
da in absehbarer zeit einen solchen
antrag stellen wird aber das wird noch
etwas dauern aber vorweg möchte ich
sagen das was uns alle gemeinsam
beschäftigt hat und was wir auch positiv
konstatiert konnten ist dass die
gemeinsame impfkampagne von bund und
ländern seit beginn des zweiten quartals
deutlich an fahrt gewonnen hat es wurden
35 millionen deutsche das sind 41,5
prozent der bevölkerung mindestens
einmal geimpft wenn man überlegt dass
der gar nicht alle impfen können weil
für die kleineren kinder ja keine
zulassung da ist dann ist das schon ein
sehr guter wert und 13 millionen das
heißt 15 7 prozent sind bereits
vollständig geimpft
es hat die priorisierung der impfung
älterer und vor erkrankter menschen ihre
positive wirkung entfaltet denn das hat
zu einer deutlichen reduzierung der
schweren kranken verläufe geführt es
sinkt die zahl der neuinfektionen und
erfreulicherweise auch die zahl der
belegten intensivbetten und das ist ein
großer erfolg und wir bekräftigen noch
einmal unsere aussage vom imz gipfel am
februar das bis zum ende des sommers
jedem bürger und jede bürgerin ein impf
angebot gemacht wird das schließt auch
diejenigen ein die jetzt zuletzt
zusätzlich wahrscheinlich in dieses im
angebot mit einbezogen werden können
nämlich die zwölf bis 16 jährigen kinder
wir haben heute zu gast gehabt den chef
der ständigen impfkommission beim robert
koch-institut der uns deutlich gemacht
hat wenn es eine zulassung der
europäischen medizin agentur geben wird
dann wird es auch in absehbarer zeit
eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission geben wirst du ja schon
zu den verschiedensten impfstoffen
gegeben hat kinder und jugendliche
können dann ab dem ende der
priorisierung sie wissen das
706 im allgemeinen die priorisierung
aufgehoben wird sich auch um einen
impftermin bemühen
entweder eben bei niedergelassenen
ärzten oder auch gegebenenfalls in den
impfzentren das wird auch jeweils von
den ländern geregelt und für uns war
ganz wichtig zwei aussagen das erste ein
sicherer schulbetrieb wird auch in
zukunft völlig unabhängig von der frage
sein ob ein kind geimpft ist oder auf
ein kind nicht kämpft ist man noch
einmal daran erinnern dass sowohl für
die kita kinder als auch für die
grundschulkinder auf absehbarer zeit gar
keine in die zulassung da sein wird aber
auch für die zwölf- bis 18-jährigen gilt
der sichere schulbetrieb ist unabhängig
von der frage zu betrachten
ob kinder geimpft sind oder nicht
gleiches gilt im übrigen auch weil das
ja immer wieder gefragt wird für die
frage des urlaubs sowohl im europäischen
ausland als auch in deutschland kann man
wenn man kein keine impfung hat urlaub
machen weil testungen dann als
voraussetzung für die urlaubsangebote
natürlich vollkommen ausreichen werden
wir haben in einem zweiten punkt uns
nochmal beschäftigt mit den zu
erwartenden lieferungen die wir erhalten
hier können wir sagen dass in großen
ganzen die liefermengen sowie sie auch
schon in aussicht gestellt wurden kommen
werden wir haben eine unsicherheit für
das zweite quartal beim impfstoff
johnson & johnson hier liegen eine
beträchtliche zahl von dosen bei der
amerikanischen zulassungsbehörde fce die
noch geprüft werden
sie haben sicherlich vernommen dass es
dort verunreinigungen in einem werk in
dem herz austria senica da ansonsten
johnson produziert wurde
diese dosen sind noch nicht freigegeben
und das davon hängt erheblich ab ob die
zugesagte liefermenge der 10,1 millionen
dosen von johnson & johnson bis zum ende
des zweiten quartals eintreffen wird
erfreulich ist dass sowohl bei antec
weiser als auch moderne
sehr zuverlässig liefern und ihre
liefermengen im zweiten quartal
einhalten werden und nach allem was wir
wissen auch wenn wir die detaillierte
liefermengen noch nicht kennen auch im
dritten quartal so dass wir eben unsere
zusage auch weiter aufrechterhalten
können die der bezüglich des angebots an
alle bürgerinnen und bürger gemacht
haben und ein letzter
diskussionsgegenstand vor die frage der
des imf zertifikat in digitaler form
hier ist ja in der europäischen union
der trilog abgeschlossen worden das
heißt wir haben eine rechtliche regelung
für die kompatibilität der digitalen
impf zertifikate das war für die
fertigstellung des deutschen im
zertifikats von großer bedeutung
es wird dieses digitale impfstrategie
tat als eine unabhängige ad geben oder
aber auch eingearbeitet in die korona
waren app da kann jeder wählen wie er
oder sie das möchte und der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat heute noch
einmal dargestellt dass er davon ausgeht
dass bis ende juni spätestens anfang
juli dieses angebot zur verfügung
gestellt wird die ersten tests laufen
jetzt ja schon
und der vorteil wird sein dass man dann
mit diesem zertifikat eben auch die
kompatibilität in allen mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union haben wird dafür
sind die rechtlichen und technischen
voraussetzungen jetzt getroffen
alles in allem also ein wichtiger gipfel
ich darf mich bedanken bei allen
bundesländern es wird mit einer
unglaublichen energie daran gearbeitet
sowohl in den impfzentren als auch in
den arztpraxen die impfkampagne mit dem
höchstmöglichen tempo durchzuführen
das ist auch ganz wichtig denn wir
kämpfen ja wie wir es anfang des jahres
gar nicht absehen konnten immer wieder
gegen mutationen und neue mutationen
das heißt je schneller wir die ihm den
impfstoff an mann frau und in zukunft
auch jugendliche bringen umso besser ist
das und ich möchte mich auch bei den
beschäftigten in den impfzentren und bei
den ärzten ganz herzlich bedanken für
ihre für ihr engagement und in zukunft
werden
juni ja auch die betriebsärzte dazu
kommen das heißt wir setzen dann auch
fast alles ein was wir haben um die
impfkampagne weiter voranzubringen
herzen
vielen dank ist es richtig dass das
heute noch einmal eine wichtige sitzung
war zu diesen gesamten sensiblen
themenkomplex des impfens und gut dass
wir zwischen bund und ländern muss dazu
auch immer wieder ganz konkret
austauschen
die drei punkte die die bundeskanzlerin
angesprochen hat waren uns gemeinsam
heute sehr wichtig natürlich wollten wir
auch noch mal hören können wir wirklich
mit großer sicherheit sagen dass wir
ende juni anfang juli einen
entsprechenden digitalen impfnachweis
haben das bewegt viele menschen wie
können sie die nächsten monate plan wird
das europaweit eine einheitliche lösung
geben eine unkomplizierte barrierefreie
lösung geben um nachzuweisen ob man
geimpft genesen getestet es eben ganz
besonders geimpft ja auch das ist der
der entscheidende punkt ja auch für
viele um diese sicherheit dann auch zu
haben wenn sie den urlaub fahren oder
wenn sie andere begegnung planen
innerhalb deutschlands oder auch darüber
hinaus das ganze thema der impfstoff
lieferungen war für uns sehr wichtig und
vor allen dingen da auch der ausgleich
zwischen den ländern und wie wir auch
lieferungen ja in den nächsten monaten
erwarten können und mit welchen
kapazitäten wir rechnen können in den
arztpraxen und in den impfzentren es ist
noch mal wichtig dass wir festhalten
konnten dass es einen ausgleich geben
wird zwischen den ländern wir haben
jetzt in den letzten wochen teilweise
ungleich die mengen bekommen das ist
nicht ganz der königsteiner schlüssel
der da eine rolle spielt oder die
bevölkerungszahl die zugrunde gelegt
wird
es kann auf grundlage der bestellmenge
und der unterschiedlichen größenordnung
der einzelnen impfstoffe die abgerufen
werden kann es eben zu diesen
ungleichheiten kommen und sehr gut dass
wir festhalten konnten dass es dazu
einen ausgleich geben wird von
herausragender bedeutung da natürlich
der dritte punkt und da ist es wichtig
und richtig dass wir klarheit
es ist der eindruck erweckt worden in
den letzten wochen als ob es praktisch
eine eigene impfkampagne für kinder und
jugendliche geben wird und das ist nicht
der fall
das muss man ganz klar sagen sondern wir
werden im zusammenhang mit den ersten
impfstoff lieferungen werden wir und den
zulassungen natürlich der emea und der
entsprechenden einschätzung der stiko
werden wir auch für die kinder und
jugendlichen in den entsprechenden
altersgruppen ein impfangebot machen
können wenn die priorisierung ab dem 7 0
fällt werden wir über die arztpraxen und
über die impfzentren sofern man das will
die länder werden da wahrscheinlich
unterschiedlich mit oben gehen ob sie
über die impfzentren noch zusätzlich
einladen oder nicht aber wir werden den
kinder und jugendlichen
wir werden den familien ein angebot
machen können
aber es ist ganz klar das muss man auch
offen aussprechen um nicht unnötig
erwartungen hier zu wecken wir haben
dafür keine zusätzlichen impfstoffe das
war glaube ich der entscheidende punkt
der in den letzten wochen vielleicht das
ein oder andere mal etwas schief
rübergekommen ist wenn einige dachten
jetzt gibt es für die kinder und
jugendlichen mit zusätzlichen impfstoff
lieferungen auch nochmals zusätzlich die
möglichkeit auch schneller ein impfstoff
angebot zu bekommen und das wird nicht
der fall sein sondern wir werden eben im
rahmen der lieferung die möglichkeit
eröffnen und vor allen dingen im total
durch das wegfallen der priorisierung
werden wir die möglichkeit eröffnen dass
man eben auch sich um einen termin
bemühen kann für die kinder und
jugendlichen und dass sie eben mit
reinkommen in diese impfkampagne die wir
ja schon aufgestellt haben also ich
glaube diese klarheit es jetzt wichtig
gewesen für viele familien damit sie
wissen woran sie sind aber genauso
wichtig ist die botschaft auch die
bundeskanzlerin schon hingewiesen hat
die einrichtung des neuen schuljahres
dann nach den großen ferien wird
unabhängig davon erfolgen und kann auch
unabhängig davon sichergestellt werden
das hat auch der vorsitzende der stiko
nochmal ganz eindeutig betont das was
wir in den ländern machen seit monaten
ist der richtige weg dass wir mit
sicherheitsmaßnahmen an der schule
arbeiten das belüftungssystem abstand
hygieneregeln maske tragen wechsel
unterricht dass das alles natürlich von
großer bedeutung war für die letzten
monate dass wir jetzt mit dem
zunehmenden im fortschritt auch für die
lehrerinnen und lehrer und daneben auch
für die kinder und jugendlichen nochmals
zusätzliche sicherheit gewinnen dass man
nicht ausschließen kann ist nach wie vor
die erkenntnis die wir auch in den
letzten monaten mitgeteilt bekommen
haben dass man nicht ausschließen kann
dass kinder auch sich infizieren
wir sehen das auch in berlin ich kann
das hier für meine stadt kann ich das
ganz eindeutig sagen ich habe
infektionen die auch beim doppelten bis
dreifachen liegen über dem berlinweiten
durchschnitt also es gibt diese
infektionsgefahren aber zum glück nach
wie vor ist dass die erkenntnis
erkrankten in die kinder und
jugendlichen nicht schwer
das unterscheidet sie deutlich von den
anderen altersgruppen also das heißt
dass wir auch in diesem bereich der so
wichtig es für viele große fortschritte
machen werden in den nächsten wochen und
monaten dass wir ein gutes und sicheres
schuljahr auch planen können nach den
großen ferien aber dass wir auch mit den
vorhandenen instrumenten und vorhandenen
kapazitäten weiter arbeiten müssen
abschließend von meiner seite auch noch
mal ein großes dankeschön an alle die
diesen schweren weg der letzten monate
mitgetragen haben
alles was wir erreicht haben jetzt die
bundesweit niedrigen instanzen alles
dass all diese erfolge sind nicht von
alleine gekommen
sie sind gekommen durch ein verstärktes
impfen sind deutlich und schneller
vorangekommen als es wahrscheinlich
viele erwartet haben und diese niedrigen
instanzen sind zustande gekommen durch
die maßnahmen die wir gemeinsam
ergriffen haben bundes- wie länder ebene
und dadurch dass so viele menschen es so
solidarisch mitgetragen haben über so
einen langen zeitraum als wir angefangen
haben uns mit dieser pandemie
auseinanderzusetzen haben wir
nicht viele von uns ich auch gedacht das
ist etwas was uns einige wochen oder
monate beschäftigen wird inzwischen ist
es über ein jahr und das über ein jahr
mit so großer solidarität die maßnahmen
mitgetragen werden das keine
selbstverständlichkeit aber das ist der
schlüssel des erfolges dass wir nicht
intensivstationen haben wo wir die frage
nicht mehr bewältigen sondern
intensivstationen haben wo wir vielen
menschen sehr gut helfen können nach wie
vor
und dass wir jetzt die perspektive haben
für die familien für die hotellerie und
gastronomie für den bereich tourismus
für die studierenden in den hochschulen
bus endlich nach anderthalb jahren
wieder losgeht und die auch wirklich
einen campus leben eine
universitätsleben auch erfahren werden
dass wir viele ältere so gut schützt
konnten wie gesagt das ist glaube ich
ein großer ein großer gemeinsamer erfolg
den man hier auch mal würdigen kann an
dieser stelle und darauf aufbauend
werden wir jetzt auch in den nächsten
monaten noch deutlicher vorankommen und
noch mehr menschen auch helfen können
danke herr ministerpräsident sie bitte
ihr herzliches dankeschön von meiner
seite mal wird es einzuschätzen haben
also erstens war es tatsächlich so
dieser gipfel hat schon ziemlich viel
klärung gebracht in den debatten der
letzten tage wo diese erklärung muss man
jetzt auch noch mal deutlich formulieren
das wichtigste ist es gibt kein
unendlichen im stoff wir haben ja immer
so die hoffnung das ist nahezu
irgendwann einem zeitpunkt wo wir im
überfluss den impfstoff haben fast zu
überlegen müssen wer kann noch
zusätzlich für impfen um die in
geschwindigkeit tatsächlich noch
aufrecht zu halten hat sich jetzt
herausgestellt auch nachdem das
internationale zusagen betrifft dass es
eben keinen überfluss gibt dass sogar
einige lieferungen nun sagen wir mal
wackelig sind so dass wir deswegen auch
sehr klug haushalten müssen wir den
vorhandenen impfstoff das heißt wir sind
nicht über den berg
wir sind auf einem sehr sehr guten weg
aber wir müssen nach wie vor schauen
dass die für impfung klappt das erste
und zweite info buden rhythmus bleiben
dass wir keine zu langen pausen haben
und dass der imf motor nicht stoppt ich
glaube es war eine kluge wichtige
entscheidung die ärzte einzubeziehen
denn die ärzte haben generell neben den
fünf cent und für eine beschleunigung
des impfens gesorgt durch die weniger
bürokratie und auch durch die
entsprechenden möglichkeiten das ist
auch richtig dass jetzt die
bei der priorisierung erfolgt es gibt
noch mehr optionen
insofern aufpassen und klug haushalte
nächsten morgen das war übrigens auch
der hintergrund der debatte jetzt mit
schülerinnen und schülern es wichtig ist
zunächst mal wir wollen ins angebote
machen aber es gibt keine impfpflicht
ist ganz wichtig das heißt da die
voraussetzung für schule eben nicht
impfen ist und es keine impfpflicht gibt
und wie auch das fest davon ausgehen
dass der schule mit anderen optionen
möglich ist wichtig klar zu machen keine
muskeln schweren aber wir wollen
angebote machen wir in bayern wollen
bereits versuchen für die ab 16
also die ohnehin schon möglich sind dort
eine impfung zu bekommen dass wir die
abschlussklassen dann im juni ein
angebot machen wären heute bereits
diskutiert dann wie gehts bei den zwölf-
bis 16-jährigen weiter die stiko hat
schon sehr deutlich wird argumentiert
die bundeskanzlerin gesprochen
dort gibt es eine große reserviertheit
gegenüber einer empfehlung dort an der
stelle und wenn dann nur für bestimmte
risikogruppen und auch vor allen dingen
nur nach rücksprache mit den kindern
jugend ärzten oder den ärztlichen
familien kinderbetreuung haben uns auch
sehr deutlich dann in der frage
positioniert und haben gesagt okay
übernahme der normalen freigabe der
priorisierung und an einer möglichen
zulassung durch die immer ist das dann
möglich aber das wäre auch die
empfehlung die wir gerade in bayern
machen würden eben nur wirklich
tatsächlich nach rücksprache mit dem
zuständigen arzt der auch beurteilen
kann ob das sinn macht oder nicht und
wie das stattfindet deswegen auch nicht
wie es meldungen der letzten tage gehabt
gibt es keinen abzweigen von vorhandenen
impfstoff kein zurücklegen
es gibt doch leider keine neuen und auch
kein umverteilen ist bewegt sich im
rahmen der normalen impfstoff basis das
war auch die entscheidende klärung die
stattgefunden hat aber und das ist
entscheidend schule ist trotzdem möglich
für bayern kann ich sagen wir sind ja
mitten in den pfingstferien sehen sie an
meinem hintergrund und auch der tatsache
dass ich heute da bin
weil wir eben gerade die pfingstferien
haben für uns ist ganz klar wir haben
jetzt noch eine woche danach pfingst
werden
und da startet unser unterricht wir
haben dann eine regelung bislang
gefunden wo wir unter 50
präsenzunterricht damit der inzidenz 50
bis 165 den wechsel unterricht wir haben
nur noch zwei überhaupt 21
körperschaften die über 100 sind derzeit
weil wir eine sehr fallende tendenz
haben in der inzidenz deswegen gleich
auch bei uns in bayern vorschlagen dass
wir nach dem pfingst zu einer noch mal
zwei wochen zur sicherheit wächst
unterricht machen danach aber überall wo
es unter 100 ist so wirklich zuschlagen
dann tatsächlich in den kompletten
präsenzunterricht einsteigen weil die
schule mögliches konzept mit dem testen
und den bereits klären hat sich sehr gut
bewährt so dass wir auch ein signal die
perspektive setzen für bayern bedeutet
das dass wir ja noch fast sieben wochen
schule haben helfen dann zwei wochen
danach wechsel unterricht und dann noch
fünf wochen wirklich tatsächlich
präsenzunterricht was für viele schüler
dann einfach noch mal ein riesen chance
es in den schulalltag zurückzukehren und
sich wieder an das konzept schule zu
gewöhnen deswegen unser wiederholt auch
ja im angebot zu machen womöglich auch
wo nötig beispielsweise bei
risikosituationen da macht es einen
besonderen sinn für die kinder
ansonsten spürte man geradezu die
zurückhaltung der stiko und fand auch
gut dass die police kann sind es auch
bewusst aufgegriffen hat und dann dieses
konzept so integriert hat also aus
meiner sicht ist es so es wird in
deutschland jeden tag besser sind jeden
tag besser ist er besser die inzidenz
fällt das heißt die grundkonzepte haben
funktioniert sowohl von der vorsicht als
auch vergriffen
und ich sage das auch noch mal für den
freistaat hat mir auch sehr bedanken
noch mal dass wir die angenehme ganz
schlimmen krisensituation nämlich als
wir große hotspot waren die zusätzlichen
impfdosen bekommen haben herr müller
sprach vom ausgleich das wird jetzt
alles stück für stück gemacht habe und
ist damals sehr geholfen habe das andere
mal bei den anderen bundesländern vor
allem auch beim bund damit geholfen hat
das dann zu sagen ich glaube es wird
jeden tag besser aber es ist eben noch
nicht so dass wir das im überfluss haben
und das ist ja kein enttäuschend und wir
haben noch eine menge arbeit vor uns
sowohl bei den impfzentren als auch bei
den ärzten also wie gesagt es wird jeden
tag besser
es gibt anders weiter zu optimismus und
hoffnung aber nicht zu übermut in
euphorie vielen dank
ihre fragen und es geht los mit kristina
dunz von md frau bundeskanzlerin und an
beide ministerpräsidenten die kinder und
jugendlichen haben
über ein jahr zurück gesteckt zugunsten
der älteren
sie haben zwar die zweifel auch der
stiko wieder gegeben aber wäre es nicht
an der zeit gewesen jetzt doch für eine
priorisierung für kinder und jugendliche
zu sorgen den schwerpunkt darauf zu
lesen
zu legen dass deren leben wieder normal
wird und frau bundeskanzlerin wird es
eigentlich bei der notbremse bis zum 30
juni bleiben oder muss das noch mal
verlängert werden
das zweite müssen wir noch diskutieren
mit dem parlament da gibt es noch keine
entscheidung die befristung ist erst mal
da und die entwicklung ist ja auch so
erfreulich wir haben jetzt im augenblick
gar keine landkreise über 200 glaube ich
und die zahl derer die zwischen 100 und
200 liegen nimmt dramatisch ab
aber wie gesagt das wird mit dem
parlament diskutiert zweiter zu der
frage kinder und jugendlichen ich glaube
dass wir kinder und jugendlichen vor
allen dingen dadurch helfen dass die
gesamt instanz niedrig ist dass wieder
das was eben gesagt wurde möglich ist
nämlich schulbetrieb hin bis zum präsenz
betrieb und je niedriger die instanz ist
umso besser ist das wir müssen bei der
frage das hat der chef der stiko heute
nochmal gesagt herr mertens in was wann
tun wir den kindern etwas gutes
überlegen ist es für kinder geboten oder
nicht geboten sich impfen zu lassen und
da wird neben der zulassung der immer
die empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission eine rolle spielen und es
wird dann sicherlich auch das gespräch
mit den ärzten eine rolle spielen das
heißt wir wollen und das ist glaube ich
das beste für kinder und eltern
diese entscheidung wirklich denjenigen
dann überlassen die der rat geben können
und das ist erst mal die empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission dass es zum
zweiten dann gegebenenfalls das gespräch
mit dem arzt und dann werden kinder und
jugendliche
also sind ja vor allen dingen schon
jugendliche ab zwölf wir können ja
sowieso für die neun- bis zwölfjährigen
keine angebot machen dann wird diese
gruppe und die 16-jährigen können heute
schon geimpft werden also das ist auch
eine möglichkeit bei biontech dann
werden alle die möglichkeit haben ist
sich um einen termin zu bemühen wir
werden nicht vom siebten juni an allen
dieses angebot geben können aber ich
glaube den kindern tun wir das
allerbeste werden die besondere
gesellschaft niedrige instanzen hat und
deshalb so viel wie möglich normales
leben wieder möglich ist mit den
einschränkungen der aha regeln die
werden auch weiterhin wald beibehalten
wir dürfen nicht vergessen bei allem was
ist wird die situation so sein dass wir
weiter in der pandemie leben und dass
wir jetzt nicht sagen können die
pandemie ist vorbei
das kann man nichts sagen sie sagen
sollten wir jetzt nicht den gerade den
kindern und jugendlichen wieder ein
normales leben ermöglichen und sie haben
recht dass es natürlich das ziel und es
tut weh dass das ebenso wie in den
früheren jahren so selbstverständlich
dass das noch nicht möglich ist aber man
muss schon sehen dass wir alle alle
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten alles glaube ich
ausgeschöpft haben was wir verantworten
konnten an angeboten auch für die kinder
und jugendlichen das war für uns im
zurückliegenden jahr oft auch eine
gratwanderung so manche erkenntnisse her
noch nicht hinreichend vorlagen oder wir
uns gewünscht hätten dass noch mehr
daten basis da ist und wo es schwierig
war allen wünschen gerecht zu werden von
den ein oder anderen eltern die
unterschiedliche positionen auch
vertreten haben von den einen oder
anderen lehrerinnen und lehrern und wir
haben alle so viel wie möglich umgesetzt
auch an den schulen und auch in den
kitas und ich weiß dass es immer
schwierig und gefährlich ist die eine
und die andere gruppe dann zu nennen
aber wir hatten über das ganze jahr
angebote in kita und schule auch jetzt
viele sagen das müsste mehr sein aber
ich bleibe mal bei meiner stadt
ich biete viel an für die
abschlussklassen ich biete wechsel
unterricht an kitas natürlich den
entsprechenden betrieb erweiterte
notbetreuung auch an den schulen und und
und
und es gibt andere bereiche die hatten
über anderthalb jahre gar kein angebot
nochmal die studierenden hatten über
anderthalb jahre gar kein angebot
und insofern muss man aber sieht man
vielleicht auch daran dass wir es uns
mit dem thema nicht leicht machen und
sagen auf oder zu sondern dass wir auch
in den zeiten wo wir extrem hohe
instanzen hatten mit augenmaß gehandelt
haben und ich glaube ich kann das für
alle sagen ausgereizt haben was nur ging
für kita und schule und für die eltern
und auch jetzt ist das der fall
noch einmal ich habe in berlin heute
ungefähr eine 35er inzidenz darüber
freue ich mich
ich habe in der altersgruppe der zehn
bis 14 jährigen eine 64er incidents das
kann ich ja nicht wegdiskutieren
das heißt ich muss an der stelle doch
immer noch vorsichtig sein und muss
schützen und mit maßnahmen arbeiten und
ich glaube so geht es vielen anderen
auch also wir richten uns darauf ein und
ich hab das ja dargestellt mit den
zusätzlichen möglichkeiten die wir haben
und mit dem impf fortschritt ja auch wir
wollen selbstverständlich nach den
ferien wieder ein umfassendes präsenz
angebot machen sei eine
selbstverständlichkeit aber wir sind im
moment noch in einer phase so wie in den
zurückliegenden monaten wo wir auch
besonnen sein mussten mit den
möglichkeiten die wir bieten an kita und
schule noch eine kurze ergänzung so mehr
natürlich stimmt ist dass dass wir den
kindern und irgendwelchen unglaublich
viel zugemutet haben im jahr
aber jetzt sage ich mal meine
einschätzung aus vielen gesprächen ich
bin echt super optimistisch dass diese
generation des überwinden wird
wir erleben es jetzt gerade bei
abiturprüfungen was ich so höre mit
großem engagement großer leistungen wir
müssen schauen dass wir manche
kollateralschäden tatsächlich
ausgleichen mit denen die ist psychisch
sehr belastet hat wo wir wo wir bildungs
nachholbedarf haben wo die
bildungsstätte auch ein bisschen
auseinander gern ist da müssen wir uns
ganz schön auf die hinterfüße stellen
und das ganze auf 383 zu bringen aber
ich hab so ein gefühl das ist eine sehr
starke generation ist die leider zu früh
viel erfahren hat aber damit besser
umgehen als ich es manchmal auch gedacht
hätte dass das eine das zweite
natürlich ist schule wichtig und
deswegen sehr viel auch dort mehr zu
machen
ich habe jetzt gerade etwas das der
bayern verstellt übrigens die tests
konzepte noch mit maske haben sich da
bewährt auch das machen die schüler und
schüler nicht bravourös und ohne ohne
klagen oder oder oder oder probleme aber
wir wollen ja beides schaffen wir wollen
der schule mit lernen ermöglichen aber
auch sicher machen es ist wieder müller
angesprochen hat aber das eigentliche
problem dass es heute gegangen ist dies
mehr impfstoff da ja oder nein
wenn es kein märchen stiftung geht es
nur darum verteilen und da gab es die
debatte verteilen wir nehmen wir anderen
impfstoffen an für stück weg und nachdem
wir immer noch viele menschen haben die
auch in den eins bis drei pro gruppen
sind die sich noch nicht geimpft dann
und bei denen eine impfung eine nicht
empfohlen erkrankung erheblichste
gesundheitliche schäden bedeutet weil es
eine abwägung nimmt man im stoff weg
oder in sozusagen speist man dass ein
und ohne die stiko wenn die stiko gesagt
wer heute
sie empfiehlt unbedingt und ohne wenn
und aber dass wir jetzt sofort alles
impfen müssen dann wäre die entscheidung
vielleicht auch etwas anders
strukturiert gewesen an denen die stiko
große zurückhaltung gezeigt hat und auch
gesagt hat eigentlich nur unter
bestimmten bedingungen
es war schon im vorfeld dieser sitzung
klar er glaube ich ist es jetzt ein sehr
verantwortbarer prozess den wir gehen
können und je mehr da ist
je mehr wird auch gehen die nächste
frage und wenn möglich bitte nur eine
nico fried süddeutsche höhe an der
stelle schon mal gerne nach hagen weil
durch die ankündigung der aufhebung der
priorisierung zum siebten juni und der
teilweisen aufhebung der priorisierung
in einigen bundesländern hat es ja schon
zu einem run auf die arztpraxen geführt
und zu teilweise chaotischen zuständen
bei der terminvergabe die botschaft die
sie jetzt an die kinder senden ist
hinten anstellen
anders kann man das ja eigentlich nicht
formulieren würden sie dem zustimmen und
ich habe noch eine technische nachfrage
wenn jetzt nach der aufhebung der
priorisierung die kinder dran kommen was
ist dann wenn die stiko aber doch in
ihrer empfehlung sagt chronisch kranke
kinder besonders gefährdet die kinder
sollen bevorzugt werden über
lassen sie das dann den ärzten naja es
ist ja heute schon so dass die ärzte da
wo priorisiert wird und das machen wir
auch die impfzentren dann vorzugsweise
termine vergeben und das wird sicherlich
auch bei einer empfehlung für vor
erkrankte kinder dann zum beispiel so
seien also da würde man überhaupt nicht
sagen hinten anstellen und ansonsten
heißt ja aufhebung der priorisierung
nicht dass sie irgendeine gruppe hinten
anstellen muss aber aufhebung der
priorisierung heißt eben auch nicht dass
jeder am 806 einen impftermin bekommen
kann sondern unser versprechen heißt bis
zum ende des sommers hat jeder einen
umständen aber es heißt eben nicht dass
ich warten muss für sich ein bericht
zugeschickt bekomme oder dass ich eine
bestimmte altersangabe machen kann oder
bissig im qr code zugeschickt bekommen
je nach bundesland sondern ich kann mich
um einen impftermin bemühen das wird
natürlich erst mal auch dazu führen dass
ein gewisser andrang da ist das ist klar
und deshalb ist ja auch die zusage
wichtig dass wir bis zum ende des
sommers jedem einem info angebot machen
werden und deshalb stellt sich niemand
in dieser großen gruppe hinten an und
wenn eine ausdrückliche empfehlung für
vor erkrankte kinder gegeben wird dann
wird eine ähnliche priorisierung statt
finden wir vor erkrankte erwachsene
das glaube ich kann man zu sorgen das
kann mal bekannten glaube ich nicht dass
man zu sagen kann so das kann man zu
sagen so bloomberg eine frage an sie
beide frau bundeskanzlerin hotel der
bayerische ministerpräsident
trotz der jüngsten erfolge gibt es ja
offenbar nach wie vor doch noch eine
große unzufriedenheit in teilen der
bevölkerung zum beispiel im saal in
sachsen-anhalt plakatiert die afd
freiheit statt corona irrsinn herr
ministerpräsident was bedeutet das
eigentlich für die union
wenn die afg dort stärkste kraft werden
sollte meinen sie das dann auch noch mal
die diskussion über die
kanzlerkandidatur in der union ausbricht
und frau bundeskanzlerin hoffen sie dass
sie mit dem versprechen bis zum ende des
sommers allen bürgern einen im angebot
machen zu können
bis zur bundestagswahl auch den rechten
populisten in winters
soll ich anfangen gut ja also sehr
spannende frage natürlich dass ich gehe
nach einer ich habe jetzt gerade gelesen
es gibt eine neue umfrage in der ard
nachdem die union da deutlich vor der
eilig davon gehe er aus reiner haseloff
und exzellenter ministerpräsident ist
der ja auch eine volle unterstützung hat
wie für alle dafür kämpfen dass in
sachsen anhalt die union vorne liegt und
eine stabile regierung bilden kann
und davon gehe ich fest davon aus und
alle anderen schlagen halte ich für
absolut reiner haselhoff mit seiner
koalition der ausgezeichnete arbeit in
sachsen-anhalt macht und was die frage
angelangt jedem ins angebot zu machen
das ist für mich eine freude aus der
sache heraus und ich glaube wir sollten
jetzt das echt nicht so parteipolitisch
denken dass ich für die union kämpfe das
haben wir dafür die spd kämpft das ist
unbestritten aber hier bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie geht es um eine
so ernsthafte sache dass wir
zusammenarbeit mit dass wir uns freuen
wenn es den menschen etwas anbieten
können was wirklich
sie schützt vor dieser pandemie und
gerade bei dem rna in stoffen haben wir
ja auch die hoffnung dass selbst wenn
mutationen auftreten wir wieder sehr
schnell einen neuen impfstoff hätten der
darauf eine antwort gibt und übrigen
können wir uns hier sowieso nur sekundär
mit etwas in anführungsstrichen
schmücken weil die impfstoffentwicklung
ist ein wissenschaftlich technische groß
leistung und dass deutschland hier ein
unternehmen dabei hat das mit an der
spitze steht das erfüllt uns mit freude
und sind uns darin bestärken dass wir
wissenschaft forschung und entwicklung
weiter gut unterstützen mit unserer
politik
wir wären holstein funke ich versuche es
nochmal bitte eine frage
es wurde ja heute mehrfach angesprochen
dass die tatsache dass die ema die
zulassung wohl geben wird und die stiko
wahrscheinlich
eine pauschale empfehlung für impfung
für kinder zwischen zwölf und 15
aussprechen wird dass es zu maximaler
verunsicherung bei den eltern führen
wird
schleicht sich die regierung nicht ein
bisschen aus der verantwortung wenn sie
sagt ja das können jetzt eltern
individuell entscheiden und da kann man
das halt mit den hausärzten abklären und
eine ganz kurze frage an herrn söder
sie haben davon gesprochen dass es ein
impfangebot bei risikosituation gehen
soll verstehe ich sie richtig dass eine
vollbesetzte schulklasse in ihren augen
keine risikosituation mehr darstellt
danke noch mal es ist ganz
selbstverständlich dass die ständige
impfkommission für sehr sehr viele
institutionen empfehlungen abgibt das
ist fortuna so gewesen sind sie malen
grippe impfungen denken da wird gesagt
besonders ältere sollten sich impfen
lassen das heißt nicht dass jüngere sich
nicht impfen lassen können aber so und
herr mertens hat heute noch einmal
darauf hingewiesen und ich glaube das
teilen alle ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten ich auch die impfung
von kindern ist ein sehr sensibler akt
das ist jede impfung ist ein eingriff in
die gesundheit und man muss jetzt fragen
wie ist der nutzen und wie ist der
eingriff und das genau das macht die
ständige impfkommission und die ständige
impfkommission wird sich nur davon
leiten lassen und das finde ich auch
richtig
das bedeutet das für das einzelne kind
und die gefährdungen die damit verbunden
sind und die chancen die damit verbunden
sind und deshalb wird sich die ständige
impfkommission so hat er uns das heute
dargelegt das darf ich soweit sagen
genau anschauen
unter den bisher infizierten kindern wie
viele schwere verläufe haben wir dort
und was kann man daraus entnehmen und
dann wird danach die ständige
impfkommission ihre aussage machen sie
wird auch das pandemische geschehen und
den einfluss der kinder auf dieses
pandemische geschehen sich anschauen und
natürlich sich auch immer anschauen wie
ist das wenn erwachsene oft sind kinder
geimpft sind daraus wird die empfehlung
seien die empfehlung muss ja nicht
heißen
oder so sondern sie wird prioritäten
setzen wir haben uns dabei ist weniger
jetzt zum beispiel erlebt da sagt man
vorzugsweise über 60 aber auf empfehlung
des arztes kann es auch so sein
die politik will kann nicht eine neben
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
geben sondern politik kann nur
ermöglichen
und da spielen die empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission eine große
rolle wenn sich denn dieses kommission
sagt die gefährdung für menschen ins
höheren alters sind sehr viel größer
dann wären wir auch nicht verantwortbar
wenn wir sagen die eltern müssen wir
aber nach den kindern obwohl die eltern
viel gefährlicher sind als die kinder
und deshalb haben wir heute dass auch
kinder werden behandelt wie alle die
nicht priorisiert sind außer denen die
vielleicht als kinder priorisiert wird
von der stiko das werden wir sehen
und die werden dann natürlich vorgezogen
und ansonsten ordnen wir das in den
gesamten bereich des nicht priorisieren
smit ein und die wichtige botschaft an
alle eltern ist schule hängt nicht von
der frage des geimpft sein sub soll noch
kein indirekter zwang entstehen für
eltern
wir haben keine impfpflicht wir haben
auch in der schule keine impfpflicht und
so ist dieser eindruck darf nicht
entstehen oder der eindruck ich kann nur
urlaub machen wenn ich ihr erstes kind
habe das wäre vollkommen falsch
herausstellen risiko bezieht sich auf
risikopatient das heißt also kinder
beispielsweise mit einer vorerkrankung
das hat die stiko ist sagt auf jeden
sparen heute schon mal dort ist die
eigentliche herausforderung denn das ist
nämlich neben der dekane erkrankung eine
ganz andere wirkung haben wir wissen ja
dass kinder eine hohe inzidenz haben
oder in der gruppe der zehn- bis
19-jährigen hohe inzidenz ist heißt es
überdurchschnittlich aber das eben die
art der krankheitsverlauf anders ist als
bei anderen altersgruppen und deswegen
ist aber bei bestimmten kinder mit einer
vorerkrankung des möglicherweise ganz
anders das uns die stiko da offener für
empfehlung diese aber beurteilung ob es
sinn macht keinem nur der arzt abgeben
denn die impfzentren haben keinerlei und
dürfen auch gar keine lag der hinweise
auf vorerkrankungen haben deswegen macht
es auch mehr sind dort über die ärzte
die kinderärzte die jugend ärzte das zu
machen also die in szene das war dahin
melanie amann der spiegel ja ich wollte
gerne wissen wie es eigentlich dazu kam
dass es jetzt keinen extra impfstoff für
kinder gibt also dass er das auch nicht
vorbereitet wird sozusagen noch welchen
zusätzlich zu beschaffen es sei denn ich
habe herrn söder falsch verstanden sie
haben ja in ihrer antwort gesagt dass
wenn die stiko sich da offener gezeigt
hätte man heute vielleicht anders
entschieden hätte
das klang für mich so als sei als
überlege man da vielleicht noch
irgendwie was nach zu besorgen und das
thema scheint ja in ihrer runde auch um
wieviel friktionen gesorgt zu haben also
hat der herr sparender ursprünglich zu
viel versprochen oder haben die länder
das falsch verstanden oder vielleicht
können sie dann noch für etwas klarheit
sorgen also es gab einen
gesundheitsminister beschluss in dem
stand das wort zusätzlich und darüber
gab es offensichtlich missverständnisse
es war nie in rhede von seiten des
bundes dass wir zusätzliche impfstoffe
für kinder bekommen könnten von den
lieferanten also von den von den firmen
sondern es war die frage wird aus dem
kontinent was in deutschland ankommt
etwas genommen um es nur für kinder zu
reservieren und damit dann aber weniger
und impfzentren also einen stent wird
immer gleich geliefert um die hausärzte
zu liefern und eine gesonderte kinder
impfkampagne zu machen und teilweise ist
der eindruck entstanden wenn man kinder
impft dann würde man vielleicht mehr ins
dorf haben als das was wir jetzt in den
lieferungen steht das ist aber überhaupt
nicht der fall
und nachdem das klar war und nachdem wir
den herrn mertens von der ständigen
impfkommission zugehört haben haben wir
uns entschieden dann die kinder ganz
normal in die nicht realisierte gruppe
mit hineinzunehmen und gleichzeitig aber
dann wenn vorerkrankungen da sind
natürlich diese zu behandeln als wäre
würden dass erwachsene mit
vorerkrankungen seien aber dazu brauche
ich keine nicht erst mal ein wegnehmen
von impfstoff um es dann gezielt für
kinder weiterzugeben das ist der punkt
gewesen also es wird dadurch auch
niemand schlechter gestellt aber es wird
jetzt so und dann hat der herr
er hat uns auch sehr dafür geworben dass
eben die besten ansprechpartner auch
kinder und jugendärzte sind für die
frage wie ist das mit der impfung meines
kindes das heißt also und kinder und
jugendärzte können heute schon impfstoff
bestellen auch sehr weil ja die 16
jährigen schon weit mit 63 17 18
jährigen schon mit bei montech geimpft
werden können das heißt wir brauchten da
auch keinen neuen kreis von beziehen
wird auf zu machen und so kann dann
entweder die ärzte bestellen oder aber
die ums zentren wenn auch in den
impfstellen von ein solches angebot
gemacht werden soll was speziell für
kinder und jugendliche da kommen wir
zurück
dann kommen wir zur letzten frage und
zwar in der den bade
die frau bundeskanzlerin sie hatten
selbst schon gesagt es gibt für das
dritte quartal noch keine konkreten
lieferpläne außer für moderne was macht
sie so zuversichtlich dass man jetzt
noch zusätzlich kinder und jugendliche
dazu kommen sie das versprechen
impfangebot für alle bis ende des
sommers trotzdem zu halten wenn es noch
keine konkreten lieferpläne gibt ja also
ich habe wir haben zwei unternehmen
haben ja bis jetzt sehr sehr zuverlässig
geliefert das sind bei und sechser und
moderner und wenn ich die angekündigten
lieferung auch wenn wir die auf die
wochen noch nicht aufgeschlüsselt haben
für den juli mir anschaue dann haben wir
in 50,3 millionen euro in ein quatsch
40,2 millionen dosen 31,3 millionen
dosen piontek für das dritte quartal
und wenn ich das zusammenrechnen mit
denen schon für impfdosen aus den
quartalen 1 und 2 und bernd quartal 4
2020 dann komme ich insgesamt auf über
140 millionen dosen
allein von diesen beiden impfstoffen bis
zum ende des dritten quartals
jetzt haben wir aber schon zwei
millionen johnson & johnson jetzt haben
wir aber schon millionen von dosen von
astrazeneca
das heißt also wenn ich darf mir alles
anschauen und mal voraussetze dass es
die impfbereitschaft nicht 100 prozent
sein wird dann kann ich also eine guten
gewissens eine zusage machen dass wir
insgesamt genügend impfstoff für die 80
millionen menschen - die null bis
zwölfjährigen 10 bis 11 jährigen haben
das sind auch noch mal um 4 89 millionen
menschen das heißt also wir müssen
ungefähr für etwas mehr als 70 millionen
menschen ein angebot machen und das
könnten wir fast alleine mit dem stoff
machen den wir erwarten und haben aber
schon erste rasierer und johnson johnson
verhilft also insofern glaube ich ist
dass die zusage die ich beten gewissens
machen kann
danke für interesse im guten abend das
war also die pressekonferenz nach dem
impfgipfel zwischen bundesregierung und
die ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
eine lange pressekonferenz gut 30
minuten hat sie gedauert da schalten wir
doch mal zu meinem kollegen thomas
reichert nach berlin der das ganze
nochmal für uns zusammenfassend wird
thomas also für alle die irgendwann
ausgestiegen sind oder gerade erst dazu
gekommen sind fast doch noch mal bitte
zusammen was dort jetzt eigentlich
verkündet wurde
also ich glaube sozusagen der zentrale
punkt um den es da jetzt heute gegen das
ist die tatsache dass ab 12 jährige
kinder und jugendliche jetzt ebenfalls
geimpft werden dürfen dass sie sozusagen
als teil der aufhebung der
inthronisierung ab dem siebten juni
denn auch geimpft werden können da
beginnt aber auch schon ein bisschen das
rätselraten oder die verwirrung die da
auch in dieser pressekonferenz wie so
oft drinsteckt denn die frage ist wie
verhält sich das auf der einen seite die
zulassung der ema mit der für freitag
gerechnet wird und auf der anderen seite
eine stiko eine ständige impfkommission
die da sehr zurückhaltend
ist der zweite punkt ist die frage der
der impfstoff lieferung auch darum gehen
wie viel können der daten wird das
überhaupt ausreichen denn nun auch
kinder und jugendliche
hinzu kommen ist das im versprechen dass
im versprechen auch ins angebot bis zum
ende des sommers ist das so auch
einzuhalten
und dann ging es noch mal eher am rande
um den digitalen im haus waren es auch
die in den stecken eine menge
konfliktpotenzial noch weil er
voraussichtlich eben erst in der juni
anfang juli kommen soll so hat es und
herr gesundheitsminister sparen offenbar
in der runde versprochen
wie dann aber all die daten die jetzt
schon in den gelben heftchen den fonds
weisen drinstecken bei denen die schon
den pigs bekommen haben wie die wieder
eingetragen werden sollen was das für
die anderen bedeutet die neugierig sein
soll
das sind alles noch offene fragen also
das sind die wesentlichen punkte aber
nochmal ich würde gerne darauf hinweisen
auf 22 sozusagen knackpunkte diese
pressekonferenz deutlich gemacht hat und
der eine ist tatsächlich dass die
erklärung oder dieser beschluss dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erst mal
relativ klar ist in der frage
kinder und jugendliche ab zwölf gehören
sozusagen zur gruppe dazu habt dem
siebten juni ab dem zeitpunkt wo
allgemein die inthronisierung aufgehoben
wird
in ihrem eingangsstatement hat die
bundeskanzlerin ihr für mich jedenfalls
den eindruck vermittelt das ist
sozusagen die ganze freigabe dann kann
aber mit dem bericht über den das
referat des stiko chefs thomas mertens
der offenbar in dieser runde im
bundeskanzleramt mit dabei war die
einschränkung die stiko bleibt bei ihr
eher reservierten haltung kinder und
jugendliche zu impfen wir haben das
vorher ja auch im interview mit hier in
zdf heute live mit gehört sie bleibt
dabei sie möchte am liebsten eine
empfehlung voraussichtlichen abgeben für
kinder mit vorerkrankungen und da
beginnt dann natürlich auch schon die
verwirrung für eltern was sollen wir
denn tun die immer die europäische
mit medikamenten agentur gibt eine
zulassung die politik gibt die in
priorisierung frei für kinder und die
stiko hat eine eingeschränkte empfehlung
also auch diese pressekonferenz der mpk
wie so viele zuvor hatte ebenfalls ein
potenzial von verwirrung und rätselraten
das ganze sei jetzt mal wieder wieder so
häufig der fall war relativ friedlich
aus muss man sagen da wurde nicht gibt
und galle gespuckt trotzdem hast du ja
gesagt es gibt viel konfliktpotenzial
wurde das jetzt wieder geschickt
vertuscht dass es eigentlich da auch
uneinigkeiten gibt über viele fragen ja
in gewisser weise schon diese diese
beschluss da der fast das schon eine
schöne kompromissformel nämlich die
tatsache dass eben kinder und
jugendliche jetzt eben zu diesen großen
pool derer gehören die per se nicht zur
prioritäten gruppe gehören aber ab dem
siebten juni eben auch geimpft werden
können vorausgesetzt sind genug dosen da
ich glaube ja ein bisschen was von der
unterschiedlichen dosierungen oder auch
von dem konflikt potenzial hat man schon
gemerkt wenn man gehört genau zugehört
hat was zb michael müller berlins
regierender bürgermeister gesagt hat und
auf der anderen seite markus söder der
bayerische ministerpräsident er vom von
lindau am bodensee zugeschaltet war
suter hat mehr betont die einschränkung
für für kinder und jugendliche das also
im grunde der arzt auf die empfehlung
der stiko hören sollte das also im
grunde nur kinder und jugendliche so war
zu verstehen
nur dann geimpft werden sollten denn
vorerkrankungen bestehende michael
müller klang ist ganz anders da ging es
eher darum dass grundsätzlich auch
kinder und jugendliche ab zwölf geimpft
werden sollen und geimpft werden können
also da ist ist eine sehr
unterschiedliche dosierungen es gab noch
ein konflikte offen zutage trat wie
gesagt wie das bei diesem
pressekonferenzen immer ist im
normierten kammerton man spricht ja vor
der presse und damit vor der
öffentlichkeit
die bundeskanzlerin hat man sozusagen
nebenbei wie der äußerung ihres
gesundheitsministers entspannt kassiert
es gab ein beschluss der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz der dahin
geht zu sagen dass eben 6,4 millionen
impfdosen für kinder und jugendliche
quasi reserviert werden um
sicherzustellen dass die rechtzeitig zum
schulbeginn dann auch geimpft sind
das wurde in dieser runde ganz
offensichtlich kassiert es wird diese
extra inflation so will nicht geben
stattdessen soll nun sollen eben kinder
und jugendlicher 12 in den pool der
gesamtbevölkerung der erwachsenen hinzu
kommen und darauf hoffen wenn man so
will dass sie daneben auch irgendwann
mal drankommen also da hat merkel hat
die ministerpräsidenten konferenz auch
hier entspannt zurück gepfiffen auch das
war ein konflikt vorher auch der wurde
offenbar in der konferenz ausgetragen
zum nachteil von spanien scheint und
vorgetragen wie immer wurde das in einer
relativ friedlichen weise im kammerton
deswegen muss man die konflikte in
diesen fällen immer er in den
zwischentönen lesen was heißt das jetzt
für jens spahn der ja doch wieder sehr
forsch nach vorne geprescht ist und auch
gleich irgendwie ein einen plan hatte
dass er da jetzt wieder zurückgepfiffen
wurde
muss ja sagen die entspannen hat eine
gewisse übung entwickelt und praxis dann
in solchen fällen weiterzumachen und im
grunde so wahrscheinlich so zu tun als
sei nichts passiert
er wird natürlich erklären müssen warum
er mit seinem seiner idee eine
reservierung von 64 millionen impfdosen
für kinder und jugendlichen nicht
durchgedrungen ist was das für die
eltern bedeutet was das für die schulen
bedeutet was das für urlaubsreisen
bedeutet was das eben insgesamt für die
familien heißt urlaubsreisen kann man
insofern eine gewisse entwarnung geben
als auch die bundeskanzlerin klar
gemacht hat reisen hängt nicht vom
impfstatus der familie habe das ist eine
frage des testens und sie hat auch klar
gemacht auch schule ist keine frage des
impfens es soll mit aller macht
verhindert werden dass der eindruck
entsteht es gebe eine impfpflicht für
schüler und jugendliche oder überhaupt
für die gesamte bevölkerung aber klar
das war sozusagen eine kleine aber ein
die klatsche für jens spahn er wird sich
dann erklären müssen in den nächsten
tagen wurde denn jetzt auch irgendwie
erläutert wie es dazu gekommen ist dass
die bundesländer relativ unterschiedlich
mit impfdosen geliefert wurden es gab ja
auch die beschwerde zum beispiel aus
hamburg da hat der regierende
bürgermeister peter tschentscher gesagt
wir haben 40.000 dosen zu wenig bekommen
woran liegt das ist das jetzt irgendwie
nochmal genauer geklärt worden
also es gab offenbar darüber eine
verständigung
das sind relativ komplizierte
mechanismen wer glaubt warum zu wenig
bekommen zu haben
aber es gab eine verständigung darüber
bei eine frühere ministerpräsidenten
konferenz zu einem zeitpunkt als wir
viel viel höher residenz werte hatten
insbesondere in der grenzregion zu
tschechien also in sachsen thüringen und
bayern oder an der grenze zum elsass als
im saarland
da wurde beschlossen dass diese
bundesländer eine art extra ration
bekommen rund 350.000 impfdosen
die zahl würde hat sich auf der
pressekonferenz dafür noch einen extra
bedankt es soll nun dafür ein jetzt im
nachgang ausgabe ausgleich für die
anderen länder geben dass es das eine
das andere ist sozusagen das
strukturelle problem das von hamburg und
auch von niedersachsen angemahnt wurde
dass ihre bundesländer
da insgesamt benachteiligt werden es
scheint dass man da zumindest gewillt
ist zu einer gütlichen einigung zu
kommen eine wirkliche lösung würde da
nicht thematisiert es ging vor allem um
die frage wie wird das ausgeglichen dass
sachsen thüringen und bayern und sagen
das saarland vor ein paar monaten extra
bekommen haben
also es bleibt bei weiteren fragen und
bei weiteren potenziellen konfliktlinien
thomas reichert vielen dank für deine
zusammenfassung deine einschätzung aus
berlin gerne und ja ihr habt viele
fragen hier im chat ich kann euch
weiterhin darum bitten dass ihr
möglichst sachlich bleibt auch bei der
verärgerung auf der anderen seite was
man teilweise nachvollziehen kann wir
sprechen jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
weiter und zwar ist karl lauterbach
vielleicht nochmal für uns da ab 19 uhr
können wir noch mal mit ihnen
diskutieren auch was gerade die frage
der impfung für kinder und jugendliche
angeht
wir haben ja gerade gehört wenn die
europäische arzneimittelagentur die
impfung des biontech wirkstoffes
freigibt das wird sich wahrscheinlich
morgen tun dann wird dass die
bundesregierung hier auch befürworten
und fördern die ständige impfkommission
frau professor omas ist auch noch bei
uns gleich in der leitung können wir
auch einmal darüber reden und wir
schalten gleich noch mal zu einer
gastroenterologen und nach bayern die
schon fleißig im chart ist ja die
priorisierung schon seit dem 17
mai aufgehoben und da würde mal
interessieren wie das eigentlich so
aussieht in der praxis bitte also fragen
was dieses ganze prozedere angeht so
wurde digitalen impfpass als auch die
aufklärung der priorisierung als auch
die frage der kinder und jugendlichen
sollte man sie impfen oder nicht bitte
gerne hier noch mal die kommentare wir
haben schon mal fleißig gesammelt weil
so viel miteinander reden konnten wir ja
gar nicht während der pressekonferenz
zugehört haben so aber jetzt schauen wir
uns erst mal die zahlen an die aktuellen
zahlen nämlich die inzidenz zahlen was
die verschiedenen altersgruppen angeht
haben uns mal genauer angeguckt und
dabei folgendes festgestellt
die sieben tage incidents sind
deutschlandweit in allen altersgruppen
in der letzten woche lag sie bei rund 63
auffällig die niedrigen werte bei den
älteren
bei den 80 bis 84 jährigen fiel der wert
auf 20,8 bei den 60 bis 64 jährigen auf
rund 47
das sind unter anderem die altersgruppen
die in den vergangenen monaten
priorisiert geimpft wurden
zum vergleich bei den 15 bis 19 jährigen
liegt die instanz bei rund 98
am höchsten ist der wert bei den zehn-
bis 14-jährigen rund 100 auch in diesen
altersgruppen sanken die zahlen
sie sind aber circa doppelt so hoch wie
bei den über 60 jährigen
also das sprechen die zahlen eigentlich
deutliche worte frau professor thomas
mitglied der ständigen impfkommission
und vizepräsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für allgemeinmedizin und
familienmedizin herrenrad gehört die
ständige impfkommission auch kollegen
die wir hier schon zu gast hatten unsere
sie auch haben sich gerade schon dagegen
ausgesprochen junge menschen mit dem
bajonett impfstoff zu impfen wenn ich
mir diese zahlen angucke wo die inzidenz
und gerade bei jungen leuten relativ
hoch sind könnte man noch sagen ist doch
gut wenn die jetzt auch geimpft werden
dann haben wir diese instanzen nicht
mehr 1 ja eine niedrige infektes jahr
kein wert an sich
dass die inzidenz bei kindern und
jugendlichen so hoch sind liegt nicht
zuletzt daran dass bei keiner anderen
personengruppe so viel getestet wird
eben bei schulkindern die tat mehrfach
getestet werden
und was wir eben auch wissen dass in
dieser person des fast niemand schwer
erkrankt das heißt selbst wenn kinder
und jugendliche sich mit gruppe
integrieren bedarf auch zwei
interessieren erkranken in aller regel
nicht schwer und damit brauchen wir auch
persönlich nicht unbedingt durch eine
werden umgekehrt dass die kontrahenten
doch noch unklar ist jetzt konnte ein
bisschen wenn sie sagen das wird mehr
getestet dann findet man noch mindestens
dienst jens über das klingt ein bisschen
nach der argument was sie ja vor allem
aus sehr skeptischen kreisen hören dass
sie sagen hat auch zu testen dann singt
die inzidenz weil die menschen sind ja
sowieso nicht ansteckend also das ist
das nicht ein bisschen schwieriges
argument argument und ich habe auch
nicht gesagt dass die menschen nicht
ansteckend sind aber die erwachsenen in
kontakt mit diesen kindern sind sollten
sich leser selber impfen lassen als dass
man jetzt vorrangig kinder impft weil
wie gesagt wenn der flüge impfung ist
schwere erkrankungsfälle zu verhindern
oder todesfälle zu verhindern dann
brauchen wir nicht bei den kindern und
jugendlichen an zusätzlichen dollar bei
den erwachsenen gerade bei den älteren
erwachsenen oder den mittelalten und
möglicherweise die gesellschaft die
hohen instanzen bei kindern
frieren damit kinder auch ihre
grundrechte zurückbekommen können das
machen wir ja bei anderen erkrankungen
nicht viel anders bei grippe sind auch
kinder die hauptüberträger aber das
heißt nicht mit dem makel
das würde ja dann heißen dass die kinder
werden viel getestet die treiben die
instanz zahlen die gesamte institut zahl
nach oben unter umständen dann auch
wieder über die schwellwerte die er
definiert wurden
obwohl sie eigentlich keinen schweren
verlauf haben dh dann könnte es dazu
kommen dass wir zum beispiel einfach
dann landkreise haben wo es eigentlich
nicht viele menschen gibt die in
schweren verlauf haben die
intensivbetten sind relativ entspannt
sage ich mal vom zumindest was gut 19
patienten an gehen eben weil wir herde
haben in schulen
das ist doch auch kontraproduktive
eigentlich oder weiblich nicht ob das
kontraproduktiv ist da wäre eben der
wert der schwellenwerte zu überlegen
wenn die sich nicht mehr in überlasteten
krankenhäusern oder in schweren
krankheitsfällen ausdrucken
symptomatischen infektionen bei kindern
das heißt sie würden dafür verlieren das
war noch nicht das heißt sie werden dann
dafür dass das man dann auch das wird ja
immer wieder gefordert aus verschiedenen
kreisen dass man dann noch andere
fertigen zunimmt belegung der betten
fall schwerer verläufe um dann wirklich
zu sehen müssen wir jetzt hier den
landkreis wieder dicht machen oder
können wir den offen halten auf
landkreisebene geht wirklich arbeiten
man das etwas großräumiger betrachten
wie zb in jedem landkreis in der
innenstadt führen gibt aber vor
politiker ja jetzt hat es hier ihr
kollege professor zepp gestern angemerkt
dass seine sorge vor allem ist das halt
zu nebenwirkungen kommt die auch
gravierender sein können er hat da
gestern hier bei uns im stream wenn ihr
bei uns auf die seite geht könnte das
ganze noch mal angucken 43 minuten dann
das gespräch zu der frage
er hatte angeführt die schweinegrippe
impfung da gab es nach einigen wochen
schon die ersten nebenwirkungen
narkolepsie das ist also quasi ja so
eine art schlafkrankheit die menschen
sind sehr müde und teilweise
gar nicht mehr ansprechbar und da gab es
dann diese fälle die nicht gefunden
wurden weil im grunde aber die
nebenwirkungen so selten ist das ist ein
relativ lang gebraucht hat um
herauszufinden dass es gibt einen
zusammenhang zwischen der narkolepsie
und dieser impfung ist tatsächlich das
risiko so hoch dass so etwas passieren
kann das jetzt sagen wir möchten kinder
und jugendliche überhaupt nicht geben
dass sie geimpft werden solange ein
wenig dann bessere datenbasis haben von
überhaupt mich ja auch nicht die rede
aber verbindet keine generelle
impfempfehlung für alle kinder und
jugendlichen
denn in der tat kann man das risiko
zumindest nicht ausschließen und das
schweinegrippe beispiel hat gezeigt dass
es so etwas gibt übrigen roten auch von
dieser nebenwirkung ganz überwiegend
kinder und jugendliche betroffen
auch das war eine seltene nebenwirkung
und neben kurzen vorlauf diese impfung
jetzt für kinder und jugendliche hat ist
das wird zum risiko verhältnis für diese
altersgruppe mit der ganz jungen ebenso
wirklich nicht gut so ich habe jetzt
hier könnte man abwarten bis man mehr
daten hat oder ob man eben vorerst auf
eine zumindest schnelle oder vorlagen in
vom platz
ich habe jetzt im chat gesehen
befürchtungen was hirnblutungen angeht
also es wird immer wieder behauptet dass
ein impfstoff zu hirnblutungen führen
könnte können sie da vielleicht noch was
zu sagen würde ich jetzt im moment nicht
wo das herkommen soll
was wir kennen vielleicht war das da der
der ansatzpunkt wir sind ja die hirn
venenthrombosen bei gleichzeitig
blutungen die vor allen dingen bei
jungen erwachsenen nach dem vector
impfstoff sondern nach dem astra zeneca
impfstoff bisher aufgetreten sind und
die dazu geführt hat dass die stiko die
empfehlung für jüngere erwachsene
zurückgenommen hat so etwas ist für die
impfstoffe bisher nichts bekannt aber
das beispiel zeigt schon auch das war
eine nebenwirkung die aus der
zulassungsstudie noch nicht hervorging
sich dann aber in der anwendung gezeigt
hat haben jetzt habe ich immer ein paar
beispielhaft die kommentare hier aus der
community schließlich mal vor andrea
margraf
youtube die stiko also der sehr
angehören sieht es völlig korrekt für
kinder ist nach aktuellem wissen die
risiko nutzen abwägung ungünstig und sie
zu impfen um die erwachsenen zu schützen
empfinde ich als unangemessen
daniel schmid ähnliche meinungen so war
das nicht genug gibt es wäre es toll
wenn wenigstens erstmal alle gefährdeten
geimpft werden egal wie alt aus meiner
familie warten noch einige alte und
kranke auf ihren termin und janet auf
facebook meint selbst die ständige
impfkommission sieht das kritisch zu
sehen keinen zwang kinder impfen zu
lassen und die politiker gehen da über
leichen
hauptsache der impfstoff kommt weg wer
jetzt noch meint es geht hier um
gesundheit dem ist nicht mehr zu helfen
ist das eine meinung die sie der sie
sich so anschließen können der letzten
gerade vorgelegten wir ein und kann ich
nicht anschließen also über leichen geht
da sich ja niemand
und dann sicher kommt der impfstoff weg
weil in der tat ja noch über die hälfte
der bevölkerung auf eine impfung wartet
darunter auch viele gefährdete menschen
auch viele jüngere oder mittelalter
erwachsene geben bisher noch nicht dran
waren und die aber sehr gerne geimpft
werden möchten und sicherlich im moment
sind voller den impfstoff für diese
personengruppe zu verwenden als
irgendwie dass von politischer seite mal
angedacht war für kinder zu reservieren
zumal man ja jede dosis nur einmal
kämpfen kann und der mangel an impfstoff
immer nach der befreiung dieser faktor
in der ganzen infrage ist so will haben
häufig werden jährlich mehr erkenntnisse
zu kindern bieten auch bekommen werden
wir müssen die gelegenheit dass sie noch
mit karl lauterbach diskutieren und ein
paar minuten da steht uns gleich wieder
zur verfügung der musste zwischendurch
beck vielen dank dass sie sich die zeit
heute für uns nehmen das ist wie immer
sehr wertvoll dass wir darüber
diskutieren können eben weil viele
fragen da sind jetzt möchten wir aber
gerne einmal nach bayern schalten zu der
internist in dockweiler manuell nada die
sitzt in germering in bayern und okay
mir wird gesagt wir sollen uns erstmal
die impfzeiten angucken dann machen wir
das also die aktuellen zahlen haben wir
auch vorliegen und wir schauen uns jetzt
mal an
das impf tempo in deutschland hat im
vergleich zur vorwoche wieder leicht
angezogen
mittlerweile sind rund 34,5 millionen
menschen mindestens einmal geimpft
worden das sind 41 5 prozent rund 13
millionen menschen sind bereits
vollständig geimpft 15,7 prozent
zum vergleich in den usa sind schon mehr
als 39 prozent der menschen vollständig
geimpft in italien 18 prozent in
frankreich sind es 15
nicht nur international auch innerhalb
deutschlands gibt es unterschiede beim
im fortschritt während im saarland rund
45 prozent der menschen mindestens die
erste impfung bekommen hat sind es in
sachsen nur 36,2 prozent der korona
impfstoff noch immer ist er ein knappes
gut im juni werden voraussichtlich mehr
als 31 millionen corona impfdosen
ausgeliefert heißt es vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium
wer sich wann wo impfen lassen darf das
dürfte vorerst auch weiter eine
umkämpfte frage bleiben
so und jetzt schalten wir nach bayern zu
doktor manuela nada in germering
internistin und fleißig am impfen wie
mir gesagt wurde
wie viele patienten impfen sie den
antrag die irgend so zwischen 20 bis 40
patienten kontakt manchmal auch
interessieren will kann den stoff
kriegen das ist halt immer unser
unsicherheitsfaktor
wir könnten denke ich wirklich so in der
aber leider noch nicht gekommen das
heisst er großes problem ist dass sie
nicht genug impfstoff bekommen oder dass
sie auch gar nicht wissen wie viele sie
in der woche bekommen
das ist genau der punkt also astrazeneca
und 2000 kriegen wir so viele brauchen
das ist in ordnung aber wir haben halt
eine lange
hatte liste für biotech impfstoff und
dann bekommen wir eigentlich nie das was
wir gerne hätten und es ist auch sehr
unsicher ist bekomme zum beispiel heute
habe ich die information bekommen wie
viel impfstoff ich dann am montag zur
verfügung habe also jetzt hat sich dann
heute jemand anstellung gesetzt und
fleißig telefoniert damit man die
termine für die nächste woche dann
bekommen das heißt wie viel
zusatzaufwand ist das für ihre praxis
und viel praxis team
das ist eine enorme zusatzaufwand wir
müssen ja mit jedem patienten mindestens
zwei natürlich von hier in andere den er
sich anmeldet und sich auf die liste
setzen lässt einmal wenn wir ihnen dann
sagen er kann jetzt zum info kommen dann
erreichen den unter umständen nicht dann
muss noch mal angerufen werden
das sind enorme aufwand man da gibt es
dann auch patienten die sache jetzt habe
ich doch schon in unternehmen ja also da
auch wenn das schon deutlich gestiegen
erst als die ihrer sicht sähen besser
wenn die menschen sich dann doch lieber
an impfzentren wenden würden wo das
ganze jahr hoch standardisierte ist und
wo es irgendwie ja alles reibungslos
abläuft weil sie haben ja noch andere
sachen zu tun andere patienten zu
behandeln
das stimmt schon aber wenn sie sich mal
die statistik anschauen und die die ihn
dann sind sie halt deutlich hoch
gegangen in dem moment als die
niedergelassenen ärzte mit allen
bezirken wurden also wenn die lebenszeit
und das alles in derselben zahl schaffen
würde und er ist sicher genauso gut aber
man hat deutlich gesehen das ist doch
noch einen schub gegeben hat dass die
ärzte angefangen haben zu impfen und es
gibt tatsächlich auch immer wieder was
die sich nicht oder nur ungern
lebenszentrum anmelden also in münchen
zum beispiel sind sie halt von ganz
münchen unterwegs an die messe also es
am anderen ende der stadt unter
umständen da schrecken gerade viele
ältere leute vor zurück dann sagen sie
oh je da kenne ich mich nicht aus und
dann haben doch etliche gewartet bis die
ärzte so weit waren also gerade letzte
woche kam dann noch so ein 90-jähriger
angeschnallt der bis jetzt noch gar
nicht angemeldet war also solche fälle
gibt es dann auch immer wieder
ich höre immer wieder aus hausarztpraxen
das ist da viel unmut auch gibt bei den
menschen die dann warten müssen oder die
vielleicht nicht den impfstoff bekommen
den sie gerne hätten dass da auch
teilweise menschen unflätig werden in
der praxis haben sie solche erlebnisse
auch schon gehabt so nicht bestätigen
meine patienten sind alle verstehen
sofort gesagt
diese und alle anderen setzen wir auch
die im küste bis jetzt nach wir jetzt
machen wir dann demnächst ohne oder ab
sofort ohne kritisieren aber die meisten
leute verstehen dass sehr wohl wenn ich
ihnen sage nach soundsoviel
priorisierung drei ihnen und sie kommen
dann aber auf die liste ich hatte da
noch nie ein problem
das heißt aber sie haben auch
schwierigkeiten so klingt das zumindest
den impfstoff von astrazeneca
loszuwerden
nein das nicht es ist nur das verhältnis
zwischen in willigen und in stoffmenge
ist besser als von zenica
ich krieg einfach deutlich mehr
akademiker im stoff und den kann ich
dann auch wirklich schnell einplanen
bei dem brand ist es halt einfach eine
mengenbegrenzung
wir haben also manchmal wirklich nur die
hälfte von dem bekommen was wir gerne
gehabt hätten oder dürfe die
zweitimpfung und das problem haben halt
bei astra nicht klar es gibt eine große
gruppe von menschen die den astra
andererseits nicht haben soll und auch
nicht haben will also bei jungen frauen
weigern wir uns auch wenn sie das
vielleicht gerne hätten sondern lebt
bitte bald bei und tag mit der freigabe
des astra impfstoffs haben wir schon
auch einen echten boom erlebt also
männer jeglichen alters die sagen die
kommen hauptsächlich unendlich geimpft
und wir klären die das risiko auf und
also wir kriegen den durchaus unter die
leute jetzt ist ja die meldung des
abends darauf haben wir eigentlich schon
gewartet das hat sich angebahnt aber ist
ja quasi das ergebnis dieses impf
gipfels dass die bundesregierung vor hat
den impfstoff für zwölf- bis 15-jährige
auch zu finden auch wenn die ständige
impfkommission sich dagegen ausspricht
oder zumindest die empfehlung nicht
geben möchte
wie ist das bei ihnen also haben sie vor
dann auch menschen unter 18 mit dem
impfstoff von biontech zu kämpfen wenn
die sich bei ihnen melden
allerdings ich habe nicht so ein gutes
gerät also ja der linie ist es ja so
dass wir noch die wachsenden noch gar
nicht annähernd durch haben und kindern
und jungen erwachsenen ist es ja so dass
die meisten verloren tatsächlich milder
sind oder sogar symptomatisch ich denke
haben eine ganz hohe dunkelziffer an
automatischen verläufen und ganz
geringen anteil von schwer zu laufen und
wenn wir dann
sehen was wir einen nebenwirkungen auch
noch den wahltag impfstoff haben ich bin
da noch ein bisschen skeptisch ich würde
es dennoch tun
ich hätte so einen einzelfall
entscheiden das heißt welche einzelfall
wäre für sie tatsächlich so dass sie
sagen ja ich gebe dir die in spitze wenn
die eltern und das kind es möchten wenn
das kind eine vorerkrankung hat zum
beispiel dann würde ich das auf jeden
fall tun geld hereinkommt mit einem kind
dem zeitig du solltest dein kind impfen
lassen diese empfehlung würde ich würde
ich definitiv nicht geben und die ich
finde wenn ich das noch so an das
argument mit der leeren immunität dass
wir die kinder deswegen impfen müssen
es gibt meiner meinung nach gar nicht ja
ich mal die dürfen nicht zur schule oder
durften werde vor allem nicht treffen
und jetzt 20 andere impfen lassen um die
alten zu schützen also ich glaub jetzt
sollte man mal andersrum denken dass die
älteren sich impfen lassen
dann stecken sie auch die kinder liegt
an den normalerweise werden bis die
kinder angesteckt werden kann
eltern das heißt die argumentation der
ständigen impfkommission und deren
bedenken dass können sie nachvollziehen
dann bedanke ich mich für ihre einblicke
in die tägliche arztpraxis und für ihre
einschätzungen
vielen dank und dann haben wir das noch
mal die gelegenheit mit karl lauterbach
zu sprechen der uns in berlin
zugeschaltet ist und auch sicher noch
mal was zu den ergebnissen des gipfels
sagen wird ich hoffe ja ist jetzt schon
da wir warten
und wenn das noch nicht der fall ist
dann gucken doch da ist herr lauterbach
sie können nicht
hallo ja ich war sehr gut wundervoll
also wir haben gerade gehört es gibt
zwischen bund und ländern auf einigen
ebenen noch etwas konfliktpotenzial
gerade was die verteilung des
impfstoffes angeht und vor allem als
auch haben wir gehört dass die
bundeskanzlerin dafür gesorgt hat dass
es eben keine kein zurückhaltend von
impfstoffen für kinder und jugendliche
geben soll da war mal die rede heute im
laufe des nachmittags von 6,4 millionen
dosen die zurückgehalten werden sollen
finden sie diese entscheidung richtig
also ich hätte mich tatsächlich gefreut
werden wir für die kinder die ins dosen
zurückgehalten hätten
weil also nach der impfung derjenigen
mit einer im priorität bleiben ja nur
die übrig ohne priorität und die kinder
und ich hätte es für sinnvoll gefunden
den kindern eine höhere priorität
einzuräumen als denjenigen die keinerlei
priorität haben also schlicht oder gas
entweder die aus meiner sicht
sinnvollste lösung gewesen
zuerst diejenigen zu impfen die noch
eine prioritätsstufe haben dann also
impfstoff zur verfügung zu stellen für
die kinder und den rest zu verändern an
diejenigen die keine prioritätsstufe
haben dann hätten die kinder ein
sonderkontingent gehabt und werten
sicherstellen können dass die kinder
nicht nachher die letzten umkämpften
sind aber die das argument auch von der
ständigen impfkommission ist ja gewesen
ältere menschen auch über 20 haben dass
ein höheres risiko eines schweren
verlaufs menschen unter 20 ihr nicht so
das heißt wenn die jetzt quasi ein
eigenes kontingent bekommen hätten hätte
das ja auch die hießen dass menschen
also junge menschen die vielleicht nicht
so schwer erkranken schneller geimpft
werden können als menschen die ein
erhöhtes risiko haben dann noch auf die
intensivstation zu landen
naja das risiko also für diejenigen die
zum beispiel eine priorisierung in der
altersgruppe 20 bis 35 erkranken sich
infizieren das risiko dass sie so
erkranken das also ihnen
bleibende schäden oder gar also
versorgung auf der intensivstation
drohen das risiko ist einigermaßen
gering und also auch die kinder sind ja
nicht komplett risikolos unterwegs aber
die dynamik bei den kindern auch
beachten
ich bin ein geringeres risiko das ist
richtig aber der unterschied ist nicht
so groß dass man sagen könnte dass hier
die priorisierung unbedingt also
einbehalten werden muss die kinder haben
ein anderes großes risiko was sie tragen
müssen nämlich wenn sie erkranken
dann fällt die schule aus wenn sie
erkranken dann also fallen sie zurück
also in ihrer entwicklung und die kinder
haben schon sehr viele also sag mal
gebüßt eingebüßt jetzt und wir kennen
das gehören wenn man so will zu
denjenigen die langfristig durch den
verlorenen unterricht und durch die
verlorene also entwicklungsmöglichkeit
also tatsächlich hier geschützt werden
müssen vor einer erneuten also situation
wo es dann erneut der unterricht aus
werth und auf der grundlage hätte ich
die kinder besonders geschützt ich habe
einfach mal geguckt was sie von einem
knappen monat gesagt haben da waren sind
gegenteiliger meinung da haben sie
gesagt ein kinder besser nicht vorrangig
impfen weil das andere schwerpunkte gibt
um die man sich kümmern muss hat sich
seit diesen knapp vier wochen so viel
geändert
naja das bezog sich auf diejenigen die
eine priorität haben und damals also gab
es ja noch viele in der priorität gruppe
3 und 4 die also noch nicht geimpft
worden sind und das ist nach wie vor
auch meine position
hier geht es nur um die frage also ob
kindern ein kontingent zur verfügung
gestellt werden soll ein gesichertes
kontingent wenn alle mit prioritätsstufe
bereits geimpft sind also diejenigen die
keinerlei prioritätsstufe haben auf der
einen seite und an die kinder und also
da halte ich es für vertretbar und auch
für im prinzip sinnvoller dass man den
kindern dann ein kontingent sichert so
dass wenn ich die situation haben dass
nachher die erwachsenen fast alle
geimpft sind
und ja eine möglicherweise dann
ausstehende vierte welle in den schulen
im herbst beklagen müssen so dass die
kinder sich dann alle infizieren
aber mit der möglichkeit dass es eben
nicht so schwer verläuft ich habe
gestern hier professor fred zepp gehabt
auch mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission der sehr auch dagegen war
die kinder zu impfen und der aber auch
was sie gerade gesagt haben dass wenn es
zu einer aus dem ausbruch von von einer
kurve erkrankung kommt oder generell
dass man kinder dann wieder aus den
schulen nehmen sollte dass er das für
einen fehler gehalten hat also er hat
folgendes zitat gesagt er hat gesagt das
war ein fehler die schulen und kitas zu
lande zu schließen wir hätten die kinder
früher rein lassen können die lock down
maßnahmen für kinder und jugendliche
sind im rückblick wahrscheinlich
überzogen gewesen den schulen sind nicht
die treiber der pandemie wir haben das
mit den hygieneregeln gut unter
kontrolle gehabt es wäre klüger gewesen
lehrerinnen und erzieherinnen schnell zu
impfen die haben die infektion in die
einrichtung getragen also da die frage
ist es tatsächlich notwendig schulen
kitas dann zu schließen wenn die kinder
eigentlich eher milde verläufe haben und
die erwachsenen um sich herum dann ja
hoffentlich im herbst geimpft sind
ich glaube dass diese also darstellung
so nicht wirklich zutrifft
wir haben ja gerade gesehen auch in der
arbeit von christian drosten und seinem
team an insgesamt 25.000 infizierten
dass die viruslast bei kindern in der
gleichen größenordnung liegt wie die
viruslast bei erwachsenen somit
infizieren sich auch kinder
untereinander und seen verzieren auch
erwachsene aber manchmal infizieren auch
erwachsene kinder und wir sind keine
daten bekannt die gezeigt hätten dass es
das lehrpersonal gewesen ist oder dass
es die erwachsenen gewesen sind die die
kinder infiziert haben was kann hier gut
gehen das ist ganz klar das weiß niemand
so genau aus im herbst kann es sein dass
tatsächlich wenn die erwachsenen alle
geimpft sind dass man dann tatsächlich
die impfung der kinder nicht benötigt
und es kommt dann trotzdem nicht zu
großen ausbrüchen in den schulen
das kann aber auch anders aussehen und
was dagegen spricht ist dass wir derzeit
also in den ländern wo die erwachsenen
zuerst geimpft werden zunehmend einer
verlagerung
also der infektionszahlen auf kinder und
jugendliche sehen
sie haben gestern noch getwittert das
habe ich mir mal angeschaut weltweit
sterben immer noch pflegekräfte und
erste weil im stoff fehlt der aufbau
großer produktionsstätten für die ganze
welt waren es im letzten jahr zu teuer
industrieländer wollten sich sparsam
selbst versorgen jetzt wird impfstoff
gehortet dass wir bezogen auf die usa
ist wichtig zu wissen also nicht auf
deutschland aber trotzdem wenn sie jetzt
der meinung sind also man könnte kinder
und jugendliche oder sollte sie impfen
obwohl andere fachleute der meinung sind
dass es nicht so eine große priorität
wäre es dann nicht auch vielleicht
klüger diesen impfstoff den mann dann an
diese kinder geben könnte anderen
ländern zu geben die teilweise ihr
pflegepersonal noch nicht geimpft haben
also es wäre auf jeden fall klüger dass
wir mehr dafür tun dass in anderen
ländern geimpft werden kann aber dass
wir jetzt sage ich ausgerechnet anfangen
zu sparen bei der vergabe des eben stoß
und den impfstoff dann in andere länder
verschenken wenn unsere eigenen kinder
betroffen sind das kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen was macht auf mich an
wenig überzeugenden eindruck wenn wir
sagen na gut die erwachsenen haben wir
jetzt versorgt da haben wir keinen
impfstoff an irgendjemanden verständlich
sind unsere kinder endlich da und jetzt
verschenken wir den impfstoff
ich finde es also tragisch dass die
industrieländer deutschland mit
eingeschlossen so wenig unternommen
haben schon also im vorfeld der eigenen
impfkampagnen das meer im stoff also
weiter produziert werden müssen
wir hätten geschlossen dafür sorgen
müssen dass mir eben stoff zur verfügung
gestanden hätte nicht nur für
deutschland nicht nur für die
europäische union sondern auch für die
ärmeren länder dieser welt und also das
kann jetzt nicht nachgeholt werden indem
wir ausgerechnet den impfstoff sparen
der sonst für unsere kinder gedacht wäre
ich war übrigens auch vor der
einschätzung dass kinder hier gar kein
risiko haben es wird immer reduziert auf
die frage müssen kinder auf die
intensivstation sterben kinder usw
das ist gott sei dank nicht der fall
aber wenn sich kinder infizieren dann
entwickeln sie sehr häufig auch längere
symptome longo wie die symptome
somit hätten wir hier
unterrichtsausfall für die also klassen
die nicht unterrichtet werden können und
wir hätten längeren oder tricks ausfall
und möglicherweise auch zum teil länger
halten schäden für die kinder sich
infiziert haben und schwer erkrankt sind
die kinder werden auch von der long pid
also erkrankungen nicht verschont es
gibt aber auch stimmen die sagen die
schäden die wir erst durch einen langen
andauernden lockdown und auch
andauerndes schließen der schulen und
kindergärten angerichtet haben die
betreffen halten nicht einige wenige wo
es das risiko gibt aber auch wo es
relativ gering ist sondern betrifft eine
ganze generation war es das wirklich
wert
was war es das wert ist es wäre auf
jeden fall so gewesen dass wenn wir
werden mehr kinder sich infiziert hätten
dann hätten sich auch mehr erwachsene
infiziert und wir hätten dann insgesamt
mehr sterbefälle gehabt die also
grundsätzliche idee dass man also die
schulen hätte aufhalten können und dass
die schulen dann sich nicht also zu
einem brennpunkt des pandemischen
geschehens entwickelt haben diese
grundsätzliche idee also kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen weil wir haben ja in den
schulen auch entsprechende ausbrüche
gesehen und wir haben auch den rückgang
der fälle gesehen im wechsel unter ich
was ich für viel problematischer heute
ist das folgende uns ist es in der
gesamten zeit kaum gelungen einen
qualitativ hochwertigen wechsel
unterricht und einen distanz unterricht
aufzubauen und darüber muss nachgedacht
werden
ich bring in erinnerung dass zum teil
auch also das lehrpersonal gar nicht
bereit gewesen wäre vor vollen klassen
zu unterrichten dass wer personal war ja
nicht geimpft und die hätte helfen
können eltern ins risiko gebracht na ja
wir haben ja auch mit den impfungen also
dann also früher begonnen
das lehrpersonal hatte dann ja eine
gewisse prioritätsstufe aber tatsächlich
ist es so also für die längste zeit wo
die brita sowohl die so wohl der schule
aussage ist zu beklagen war hatten wir
nicht den impfstoff für die aus
das lehrpersonal für die eltern und
daher war der wechsel unterricht und ein
qualitativ hochwertiger distanz
unterricht das war unsere pflicht und
das ist in vielen bereichen nicht
ausreichend gut gelungen
ich habe jetzt noch eine frage von sie
an sich nicht verschulden sorgt ein
bisschen länger gewesen sind ein
bisschen länger schon also eine frage an
sie von radio parallax auf youtube wie
sollen sie fragen warum hauptsächlich
nur noch über kinder gesprochen wird und
nicht erst die 30 bis 50 jährigen
komplett verimpft werden das ist ja auch
eine erfahrung die viele menschen machen
sie versuchen einen impftermin zu
bekommen sind pro gruppe 3 teilweise
noch zwei und werden trotzdem nicht
geimpft ist das tatsächlich jetzt die
nicht der richtige zeitpunkt schon
darüber so zu diskutieren das auch jetzt
schon zu beschließen
also es ist der richtige zeitpunkt
darüber zu diskutieren aber es muss bei
dieser gelegenheit auch noch einmal ganz
klar gesagt werden das ist also nicht
akzeptabel dass wir hier noch immer so
viele haben ihn priorität gruppe 2 und 3
nicht geimpft sind also mittlerweile
also ist er im fortschritt also soweit
bereits das im wesentlichen diejenigen
die also in priorität gruppe 32 befinden
hätten geimpft werden müssen
ich habe ja auch ein kommentar von
stefan schäfer der das bestätigt er
schreibt priorität 2 ist noch lange
nicht fertig ich warte seit zwölf wochen
in niedersachsen da ist aber immer noch
erst im stop das kann doch eigentlich
nicht seine lauterbach oder also es kann
nur erklärt werden indem es auch viele
gibt die bereits geimpft werden oder
geworden geben vorn sind die kanne
prioritätsstufe hatten denn sonst hätten
dann mit dem impfstoff der bisher zur
verfügung steht hätte man also die
zumindest die priorität gruppe 2
komplett impfen können hollerbach dann
danke ich ihnen dass ihr heute für uns
wieder zeit hatten die fragen
beantwortet haben und sich positioniert
haben ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und zum ende dieses live
streams haben wir noch mal an was
bundeskanzlerin merkel zusammenfassend
gesagt hat über die frage wie das sind
impfungen für kinder jetzt weitergehen
soll
wir bekräftigen noch einmal unsere
aussage vom imz gipfel am 11
februar das bis zum ende des sommers
jedem bürger und jede bürgerin ein impf
angebot gemacht wird das schließt auch
diejenigen ein die jetzt zuletzt
zusätzlich wahrscheinlich in dieses im
angebot mit einbezogen werden können
nehme ich die zwölf bis 16 jährigen
kinder
wir haben heute zu gast gehabt den chef
der ständigen impfkommission beim robert
koch-institut der uns deutlich gemacht
hat wenn es eine zulassung der
europäischen medizin agentur geben wird
dann wird es auch in absehbarer zeit
eine empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission geben wirst du ja schon
zu den verschiedensten impfstoffen
gegeben hat kinder und jugendliche
können dann ab dem ende der
priorisierung sie wissen dass am 7.6 im
allgemeinen die priorisierung aufgehoben
wird sich auch um einen impftermin
bemühen
entweder eben bei niedergelassenen
ärzten oder auch gegebenenfalls in den
impfzentren so und was alles noch mal
schriftlich haben möchte bitte einmal zu
instagram wechseln da haben wir einen
scheck mit allen ergebnissen des
heutigen impf gipfels ich bedanke mich
für das zu sehen ich bedanke mich für
eure fragen und kommentare und sagt bis
zum nächsten mal macht gut und tschüss